this is jocko podcast number 278 with
echo charles
and me jocko willink good evening echo
good evening
it's a little cold outside
but it doesn't matter
nothing else matters right now
except doing my job right
this job
i take another step as gently as i can
as quietly as i can
this is where it all matters
i can't let them hear me if they do
they'll be gone
and i won't get my shot
i take another quiet step i see my buddy
freeze
he sees them
they must be in range
my buddy slowly looks back at me and
gives me a nod
it's go time
i prepare my weapon
by now i know this weapon
well i've shot thousands of
rounds through it in the last year for
this moment
ever since i was a little kid it's been
this way
stalking through the woods closing the
distance
trying to see without being seen
my adult life was much of the same
sneaking around
in the woods or in the desert or in the
city or in the jungle
i take a few more steps and find some
cover by a tree
this will keep me hidden
my buddy gives me a hand signal he's
given me the range
nothing else matters i initiate the
procedures
my mind is full but it's empty my heart
is beating but it's steady
it all comes down to this moment
i'm alive
now that may have sounded like a combat
scenario
but it wasn't it was a description of a
more recent pursuit of mine
bow hunting and the buddy
i reference is a real person
a real person who's a incredible archer
an amazing hunter one of the best
coaches i have ever worked with in
any discipline and most important a
friend
that is always ready to help not just me
but an entire community of people
the world renowned founder
of knock on archery john dudley
dud what's up man thanks for coming on
to finish that story
that was awesome it was like fire right
yeah and especially this season where we
were
on a lot of bulls and that happened that
little that little thing played out
time and time time and time again and i
ended up not getting any shots off but
man
it was freaking fun
all right man let's go there's a lot of
people that really
don't know much about you and let's
let's go back to the beginning
cause i have heard
piece together stories of your life and
there's a lot of good ones man
it's always surprising that you're here
you weren't arrested you're not in
prison
you're not dead you know there's a lot
of different avenues you could have
headed down
dang right yeah just a horrible
i don't deserve my wife or my son
because like
all the time i'm just like karma like
he's that real
patient sniper and at some point like i
don't think he's
made any fires yet if he has they've
been
off so much i haven't heard him come by
but like i'm still waiting
just to get sniped because i i deserve
it if it happened
all right so where were you born uh fort
bragg
because your dad was in the army yep yep
and and
is that where you did you spend any time
in fort bragg do you remember to spend
any time i don't remember it no i don't
remember it because it was uh
i was it was 76 and then i think by 77
we were in the
mississippi delta yeah was he still in
the army
uh no i think he just got out and then
what was what did he do once he got out
of the army
uh he was a he was pretty much like bill
murray he was a groundskeeper for a golf
course while he went
to college you know after getting out of
nom you know came back
he was like he was like 100 percent
you're like freaking scoping out gophers
and wait this is caddyshack bill murray
yeah yeah okay yeah i remember
i remember like being with him in that
golf cart
cruising around and he went to
and this is stuff i haven't even talked
to him about this is just from
memory from that long ago but i'm sure
he went to delta state
in cleveland mississippi my mom worked
for baxter healthcare
and that's why i think we were there and
so my dad went to
college for psychology and
you know i remember plugging
learning to plug holes on the golf
greens and and smoking that first ball
washer with the golf cart when i was
like i don't even know how old i was i
just know like
you know my dad being like bring that
golf cart over here and it was in
reverse and i just stomped on it and
just drove over
the ball washer that's the first time
karma made a little that's the first
time karma started to go wait a second i
need to be tracking on this dude
yeah i mean i wonder what my dad would
think like
you know damn is that a sign like that
would have been a
that would have been a real easy one to
get
to get over yeah because it just
i was i was a tornado for a while
where so where'd you do like the bulk of
your like when you were in
let's say like sixth seventh eighth when
you start actually you know figuring out
the world and
all that where are you in um
it would have been illinois we were in
the delta
until i was seven i think and then my
mom got transferred up to
northern illinois um to work for baxter
and that's kind of where i grew up and
when i came up there
honestly i was a little bit rebellious
i'm not really sure why
i just uh i don't know just what i was
into
like i was a skater and honestly there
was um
i enjoyed skating i enjoyed like
freaking ninja movies and
so i like i built ramps and you know and
people and
i was just like a punk in northern
illinois
that you know when when everything was
like skate or die and there's
you know all these like anti-skate
things that was me
so yeah at school you know
it there there was definitely a little
bit of
i don't know hate towards skating then
and i wasn't
like i had no drive athletically
i was just wanting to like
pierce my ears like play with fireworks
you know blow stuff up
just like you know my first construction
job i said was building ramps
i mean i had ramps all over the place
my sister freaking hated him how good
how good at skating were you
um i would say i was
just below intermediate
is it something were you how many hours
a day were you skating
like a lot yeah i had half pipes with
some quarter pipes
what's up with the stellar level of just
below intermediate
because the only instruction i had was
watching the search for animal chin
freaking every day like
in a big box of cereal and then go out
and just
try to get after it so what at what
point or what was it that made you start
doing athletics sports
you teeing me up for this uh so it i
think
yeah is there some weird stuff yeah
cause my dad was i always knew my dad
was a super athlete
you know he was my uncle and you know my
mom
always told me how athletic my dad was
and um not to mention he was just good
at
you know anything like honestly even a
skateboard
he's just like what's that and i oh i
you know i'm learning to skate on this
half pipe and he's just like oh let me
check it out and then you just do it
meanwhile you're just over here driving
into ball walkers
exactly but uh no i i
like i said i liked fireworks and liked
you know
blowing stuff up and you know one thing
led to another and
freaking burned my house down at 10
years old
or 11 maybe 11. i mean literally yeah
yeah everything except for what was in
my dad's car while he was at work and
what was in my mom's car
while she was i think in puerto rico on
a business trip how old were you
i think i was like 11 or 12. how did it
happen
playing with fire freaking lit
some stuff on my bed on fire and then
like
put it out called my dad and my dad
you know he's like did you get it out i
said yeah i got it out and he goes is
there smoke in the house i go oh yeah
there's freaking tons of smoke and he's
like
open up all the windows he said you know
he's like i hate the smell of smoke you
know get that [ __ ] out of there so
i opened up everything and he's like go
open up the windows and everything come
back and
tell me what's going on so i came back
to the phone i'm like open up everything
it's smoking but smoke's going out
so he talked to me for a little bit and
then
he said well go check on it go back down
and check on it and i went down and when
i went down it was like engulfed because
i just
gave it oxygen you know i didn't
like if i would have just like taken
that blanket
and like you know if he would have just
said go throw that blanket out in the
yard
like game over but you know i put it out
and then
freaking fueled like open the front door
open the window and just
freaking gave that thing what were you
burning like like matchsticks were you
burning like
i think i was uh just playing
flamethrower with a lighter and some
aqua net
that my sister had
and so it so so the whole house
burns down oh yeah everything
yeah everything and so it was
i mean i don't really know what kind of
conversation my parents had
because they never they kind of asked
what happened or something
you know but they never like made me
feel horrible about it
and then they just let you i mean you
must have felt like freaking horrible
though oh still do
i mean i laugh about it now but yeah
like i think about
you know because like all my dad's
you know all my dad's military stuff
like every picture he had from you know
as a child you know like everything we
had every single thing i remember
it was in the winter so everything like
froze like after they put it out
and i remember digging through it with
my dad you know we were like
digging through the thing like a couple
days later just trying to
see what you can find and i remember we
like we were digging and
found this like closet that was in right
inside our front door and it
like fallen through and the like the
glass doors were there and i remember my
dad
you know shucking the glass doors open
and he had a pair of
these like lacrosse winter boots and
they looked
brand new and i'll never forget how
excited
he's just like my boots man he freaking
grabbed him he's just like my boots are
okay and i and i remember like that was
it
like other than what he had in his the
trunk of his car and what he wore it
that day like that was it so then we
you know started rebuilding naturally
i was a skater and not to mention
uh 10 years old i was
5 foot 130 pounds so i was like short
and fat
you know short and chubby and so
you know short and chubby skater you
know wasn't an athlete
so then you know my dad could tell i was
i was bummed out
you know and so he kept telling me like
you need to go
just go do something you know just you
know go get active hang out with your
friends like you know he doesn't want me
to like sit around and get depressed
about it
so they talked me into going out to like
a school
dance or something you know this is
whatever
fifth grade or something i remember
going and they they said like this
hey this song's dedicated to john dudley
and it was burning down the house
someone had
one of the kids some jocko
over there sent that one my way that's
unfortunately that's exactly what that's
exactly my mode
when i was a kid to be a little freaking
savage
yeah so then that's amazing that your
parents
recognized that you felt enough
guilt on your own without having to just
turn the screws on your brain to make
you feel even worse about it yeah i
don't know if i could have done it
like i don't know i don't know what the
conversation was they've
never brought it up and there's been
times where we've talked about
the fire you know that's kind of how
it's referred to
but they've never gone into detail like
my dad's never said like yeah man i knew
if i freaking
threw that [ __ ] on you you know it'd
crack you or whatever
but what happened was you know and you
know maybe this is
just my dad's psychology but uh
what happened was after that dance my
dad knew like we need to get this guy
out of this town so we moved about 45
minutes away
and without him ever tell like saying
anything to me
i knew when i moved like i need
i need to freaking make it right with my
dad
so that's when i went and started
i'm just like you know he's i know he's
always wanted to be
me to be an athlete so like i need to
get my [ __ ] together and
start getting into sports and this is
how how old are you
i think i was because you keep saying
like 10 12 10 12.
well there's a big difference between
2010 yeah i think the
i think the fire was when i was 10
and then we probably moved when i was
11.
yeah because then by when i got into
junior high school that's when i'm like
i'm gonna be an athlete
what did it start with what was the
first sport uh
basketball um
well yeah i think basketball football
you're just all in yeah basketball
football
running and then you know there was you
had no experience playing basketball
let's say
my dad always shot hoops yeah a little
bit
but then i started growing so i was like
i remember at 10
i've got this football card and it says
like
it has your stats on the back and i
think my grandma gave me that photo
because we didn't have any pictures
you know going back pre-fire so i was
like
five foot 130 pounds i was like chubby
then when i was a freshman
so what is that 13 12 12 13.
13 year freshman i think so then on that
on that one i was
six three 130 and then by the time i was
senior i was six
five 205.
so i just like stretched out and just
looked like this gumby going up and down
the basketball court you know my dad's
like i always
felt like if you tripped it'd sound like
a chandelier breaking across the ground
how much would you prac like okay so you
get into basketball
do you start saying because i mean
that's that's a for you to make a
transition from like hey i'm a skater
with freaking
whatever you probably had like the tony
hawk bangs and stuff like this
hell yeah so you had the tony hawk bangs
then you're like all right i'm going to
be a basketball player
you get a crew cut you start freaking
training is it like that kind of
are we talking rocky uh what's that
thing called montage is there a montage
going on no not really because i still i
mean i still
liked you know getting in trouble and
freaking blowing stuff up and you know
ordering fireworks wherever i could or
egging some houses or you know whatever
kind of mischief
st i stole my mom's minivan one time she
had this
she had this pontiac transport you
remember those ones it was like a wedge
like the sloped note yeah because
eventually my parents got divorced and i
can't remember when it was it was
somewhere
you know junior high or something like
that but my mom
traveled a lot and i was home on my own
a lot
um and so i remember you know my mom
would have
like cars take her to o'hare and so i
remember one time like
i'm just gonna go take that van out for
rip you know and i'm
just like all the ball washers in
you know all in illinois yeah
so i'm driving around you know seventh
grade
just driving around my town in this
minivan and
one of my buddies was on his bike like
driving down the road
so i pulled over i'm like what's up man
and he's just like holy [ __ ] did you
steal a car i'm like yeah it's my mom's
and he's just like ah and you know and i
i thought i could drive pretty decent
because i had
uh my dad would never let me get like
motorcycles or anything
for obvious reasons but he let me get a
boat he got me a
a 12-foot boston whaler with a 25 horse
on it
so that's like i put a thousand miles
on that freaking thing dude i mean my
dad would fill up that little five game
five gallon gas can and uh the
fox river chain was only a block for my
house we live like right on a channel
so i just drove that boat all the time
so to me the minivan was
gravy right no current
you know didn't have trim tilt like this
was
it wasn't a pull start this was freaking
gravy
but uh i'm sitting there talking to this
this
kid and i see someone coming up behind
me in the mirror so i said i go hold on
let me freaking whip over you know and i
remember putting in reverse and trying
to like
do a little you know whip in but that
long beak on the front of that freaking
minivan i ended up
swiping this dude's like back pegs and
like took him out underneath
like the front of the car and like bent
the back of his bike up a lot
so then i ended up having to you know
trade him like my good bike i had a gt
you know i had to trade him like a good
freaking
a good bike for the huffy yeah for this
freaking huffy that he had
and and i'm just like you're not gonna
say nothing he said no but
you know looking back you know if
any of our kids rolled in with a brand
new freaking gt
you know with the gyro on it freaking
pegs on the front and back
you'd be like hey whose bike did you
steal
so anyway you know fast forward today
i'm knarked out
always always happened
the kid broke bro he broke big time this
day i was like where the hell did you
get dropped by
me gave me hit me drove over me in the
car
yeah it was just you know stuff like
that yeah then you hear like wait
john dudley that little kid was driving
his mom's car i'm going over there right
now
yeah i don't think anyone wanted to get
close
because yeah i mean i had i had freaking
straight bangs down here slung it
and uh yeah just i think i think
when i got into sport there and
originally i didn't want to
really play football i was supposed to
play golf
like my dad said don't play football
you're not you know you're too brittle
go play golf and when i went to the high
school
like the tough kid in school came up to
me and goes
hey what are you going out for because i
was standing in the line and
he's and he said i go i'm going out for
golf he's like no you're going out for
football
and i said no i'm going out for gol i
have to do golf
and i remember he said uh well we need
enough guys to scrimmage
and he said you know i'm quarterback so
he's like you're signing up for football
or i'm going to beat your ass
so i freaking signed up for football and
never told my dad for
like until he saw me in the paper
what do you see you in the paper for
well because i ended up becoming
quarterback
and like taking that kid's job he was
saying
i would take my golf clubs to school
because i'd say like
he's like how's golf and i'm it's all
right
but i was playing football because i
kind of had to and i started out as like
defensive end and then tight end and
then
i think i like chucked a football back
you know i think i caught a pass and
like win in the end zone
and then the coach is like hey throw the
ball back and i think i just freaking
just hucked it and you just like whoa
you know wait a minute so
yeah just one thing led to another and
um just
i think i think i
loved i don't know just the constant
challenge
it's hard to describe but it's like
if i know i'm not good at something
which i really had never
fueled that then it didn't keep me
coming like i'd get bored with it
but if i if i wasn't good at it or
if i knew that i had room for
improvement then then that's the things
that i progressed at but it just kind of
got to the point where
no matter really what the sport was i
felt like i could do it above average
and then i honestly like my body started
to change so it went from like
me being like the short fat
skater to now i'm you know
second tallest kid in the school and and
growing and
you know becoming an [ __ ] you know
just kind of being
you're just growing up just being like
overly confident
you know but i felt i just felt so much
confidence just
it was like gas just sports for me
was just gas because it's like oh you
want to do track okay
go do track what did you do in track
um high jump triple jump whatever i
wanted
pretty much honestly uh 100
200 400 and you did good at all of them
yeah i mean i did for my team yeah i did
good
did you did the coaches like try and
keep you focused on one thing i think
yeah um like the idea that some people
have that the best thing to do with
their kid is put them in one sport when
they're four years old and just keep
them focused on
and then other people are like hey have
your kids play a bunch of different
sports and it's going to make them more
well-rounded in the end
well it's in a way you look at it like
functional fitness now
it's proven that you know if i would
have had more functional fitness in my
lifestyle
i would be feeling a little bit better
today than i did
pre-surf you know for the first time
with you
um because like some of my stuff is
smoked probably because it's not like
functional fitness
and i'm i'm a you know i feel like the
reason
i still today do good at just random
things i pick up
is because you know in when you do
different sports you also get street
smarts
in athletics you know that's the thing
like there's book smart people and then
there's
street smarts people and as like an
employer
i you know i'm not i don't look for a
degree
i look for work ethic and i look for
someone that
you know when they pull up and i look in
their car it's not a freaking
wreck it's not trashed you know and i
look for people that have
certain types of work ethic qualities
because for me as an athlete i feel like
even though i wasn't like the pinnacle
of
all these different sports i also
learned different mechanics
and different like you know physical
smarts
from doing a lot of things and
i always i always wanted to do good
enough at it to where i felt like
i could put it down and pick it up and
still
like represent it well you know if i
felt like i
if i did it and look like an idiot in
front of people i'd want to do it more
until i could get it figured out but
my son you know coming from
england he was into soccer first so he
came over and you know he played soccer
quite a bit but
over here soccer's like a one season
thing so once he got into junior high
you know he tried football and i
realized that just wasn't his thing you
know
it it just wasn't you know getting hit
and stuff just wasn't his thing
but he was like always fast you know
he's always fast and
and he likes i mean he
he performs at his highest if especially
when he knows someone's pumped
about the fact that he just did good
so uh i ended up talking him into
swimming because he did um
let's see he did soccer i knew soccer
was coming up we talked him into cross
country
and he didn't really like the people
loved the coach
awesome coach and then i talked him into
going into swimming went into swimming
swimming had a a freaking awesome
instructor
military dude um super disciplined
swam like honestly for how young he was
i was like
okay these guys are crazy two days like
sharon's getting up at 4 30
having him to the pool at 5 15
they'd do an hour practice and then
shower and then she'd get him home to
feed him before we'd take him to junior
you know whatever high school or
you know whichever so he had a pretty
like
awesome schedule i thought you know i'm
like this guy
andy was getting straight a's which
i don't ever remember taking a book home
like i didn't i don't even remember
being assigned books yeah
part of it was different back then bro
it was different back then like
i mean like i didn't do like i see my
kids my kids will have
and they're older now but when they were
in school it was like homework
every day from day one from like
kindergarten
on through high school hours and hours
and hours of homework
i never did homework homework was not a
thing
and i i wait now let me rephrase that
it was a thing it did exist i knew that
it was a thing in existence but it
wasn't a thing that i was doing
right it wasn't like oh it's you know
it's in the afternoon i'm going to do
homework now it was like the afternoon
i'm going to throw rocks and [ __ ] like
yes that was
that was where i was at so what what
sports did you end up
playing because i know i like you
rattled off one time to me you're like
oh i did freaking wrestling i did
basketball i did football i did baseball
i did tennis i did freaking you did
everything
yeah well you just named them all yeah
yeah i mean i did
i did quite a bit i wrestled a year um
mainly because i did basketball really
didn't like the coach
and just i'm like i freaking hate this
guy
so then i went and wrestled and coming
into wrestling
as a sophomore and we had a really good
wrestling school too
like both the guitars are from that's
right yeah you told me that yeah so like
jason was my guard and and clay was um
a little bit younger but you know we had
a fired up was clay guido when he was
14.
cause dude he's 30 whatever right now
he's still fired up let me just tell you
clay or uh well jason
was jason was like on a clay level but
like more like more of a gorilla
you know clay gives jason a lot of
credit for for being a savage
and trust me he was um
every game he like before every game
he'd take a mouthpiece
out of a packet and we'd put it on his
helmet
and then he was like my pulling guard
and i remember
like by fourth quarter i'd be like
grabbing his mask
i'd normally like grab his face mask to
like call plays
and i'd look and it would just be like
the plastic
piece like because he would chew he
would just he would eat him like
he would eat a full mouth piece and his
eyeballs were like
this big around wait this is jason or
clay
it's jason yeah jason and i remember uh
i remember one time like him and him and
his brother
lived in a a part of town that was like
you know um
i don't know there's a lot of savages
over that way you know there's like
a lot of like wrestlers came from that
group of town there's a lot of badasses
over there
and i remember one time like jason came
to practice and he was kind of pissed
because
he was like chainsawing something on his
garage and the chainsaw kicked back and
hit him in the top of the head and like
chainsaw his head open and dude
he just threw his football helmet on and
freaking got
after it dude like that right there i
was just on uh
on jordan jason and i wrestled the same
the same weight class which was what i
think
171 in our sophomore year
but he was like way better i was just on
jordan peterson's podcast a little while
ago and he was like talking to me and i
was like talking about how
like when you're a young kid and it's
not everybody
but you just want to like fight and go
and
that's my picture when you picture him
just gnawing apart his freaking
mouthpiece and his eyes are all big
this kid needs to go to combat somewhere
like that's what he's meant to do
and he did and he and he did
so so you wrestled for what a year yeah
wrestled for a year look i don't care
how good of an athlete you are
you roll into wrestling and did you not
just get
like crushed oh yeah okay yeah yeah
yeah you can't catch up you know no i
wrestled kids
yeah i wrestled uh i wrestled jv and i
mean they were
that we were a wrestling school like you
know we we had
we had some really good wrestling
coaches
and yeah it was it was tough
it was tough but i really i was still
like getting into my body
honestly because i stretched up so high
and so i didn't have a lot of
coordination
but i had work ethic you know that's one
of the things
before like before i go down that route
like with multi-sport thing
with my son he did swimming after cross
country and then when he got to soccer
like he started the coach wasn't playing
him but
at practice this this coach was taking
weeks to try to condition
the other player but harry would be out
there just
running circles around people because he
just got off of cross country followed
by
swim season followed by now it's soccer
season you're just running around out on
some grass you know so he for him it was
nothing and i i remember
after like three or four games of
watching the coach just
bypass him i kind of pulled the coach to
the side after
practice and i said hey i said is there
anything i should be working with harry
on
so he can get more game time
and he just said well i don't like
single player
you know he said i want soccer players
harry's too distracted with other sports
and i was just like really
you know i said i deal with a lot
of coaches on
pretty high levels and i said i've never
known a coach to not want an athlete on
the team
i'm like this this kid's an athlete an
athlete as opposed to a sport specific
one trick one trick pony yeah um
and so yeah right then i just kind of
told harry like
i don't think soccer's your thing so he
went into track and
you know did cross-country track and
swam four years even though he didn't
like it you know still did it
and then you know ended up going to
college to run and
and still gets awesome grades and runs
and does all that stuff
and he's kind of like like i was but a
little bit later he's like
now getting into his into his body to
where
and he's also hit a new gear of
competitiveness which is really cool to
see
because i hit that way earlier you know
i would get
probably what held me back athletically
is i would get really
pissed off you know it's like once i
started to compete
i hadn't ever been taught the management
of like
you know raging out when you like made a
bad play
or through an interception or something
and that that actually transpired all
the way into my archery career
and then luckily um an olympic coach
like help that
that was a big turning point in my
career like in my 20s when
i got taught like how to get you know
how to not let
the arrows in my quiver that haven't
been shot yet be affected by
the ones that already have and that you
can't get back you know
that's kind of how it was put to me so
that really helped but in high school
i think by the time i hit you know
junior and senior year i just started to
i just started to feel way more
confident in what i was doing and
you know size wise you know i was
a totally different person than
what i was so what ended up being like
the sport
football for sure yeah football was
was the sport and for me um i've always
struggled with sleep
you know i've always just you know been
an insomniac
and i also one of the things that kept
me awake was
knowing if someone else was like having
more time to train than me
so you know i was welcome to my world
yeah so i was like in high school
by my senior year you know i was like
substituting
any non-elective class that i had or all
my study halls
for like x or gym so i'd go to like four
gym classes
and then i had my my football coach gave
me a key
to the to the gymnasium so when i
couldn't sleep at night and my mom would
be gone
you know i was home i was home alone a
lot
you know i had my mom would just sign a
checkbook for me to like order dominoes
you know and whenever i woke up i'd go
to the high school
go in there and i had you know my coach
gave me this huge bag of footballs when
i was a sophomore
and just said like these are yours until
you graduate and so i'd just go to the
gym and i'd pull the laundry baskets
you know out of the locker rooms and i
just throw
you know from corner of the gym to
corner of the gym i just
run like three-step drills and just like
run 73 passes
into those or then into garbage cans or
then eventually just like
throwing into the basketball hoop and
then just doing like three step drops
five step drops seven step drops roll
outs and just
and then it got to the point where it's
like i memorized what i needed to do but
then i memorized what the linemen need
to do
and then ever you know like every player
on the field it's like this is
you know i knew the playbook front and
back and how how good was your team
sucked horrible how'd you guys do senior
year horrible
you know just really underperformed at
all the camps we were awesome
because at camps how should you have
done
i mean were you from like a week school
a week football school
from a good football school you guys
were just playing shitty no
you know it it's kind of like um
it's kind of like when you i forget what
podcast it was but or maybe it's in your
book when you were talking about
um through buds they were the two teams
with the two different boats
you know i remember like one of the
sayings my football coach always would
have would he'd be like
you know bring the boat in you know he
always would say like the boat's lost
he's like it's your job to bring the
boat in you know and he was like
your job meaning you john dudley yeah
because you're the quarterback yeah
i was responsible for every mistake we
made
you know if we screwed around and
practice got shut off early
he would he would like pull me back and
tell me like
you're gonna run laps for every person
here that's screwed off today and today
there was
you know we freaking 46 minutes early we
quit practice i want 40
46 laps you know it'd be like stuff like
that
but we had a small group of people for
like seven on seven camps that were
at all the they were at all the camps
they
i would call them and say let's go
practice
but there was and we at seven on
seven we were great but there was
you know four other people that weren't
being included
and then the entire defense so we were
just
we had really good pieces
but nothing ever like flowed as a team
did you did you do good enough did you
get looked at by colleges
yeah i think the first college i think
the first college that looked at me was
ball state when i was a sophomore i
remember
at the end of my sophomore year i went
to ball state with my mom
and that was like that little totally
different fire because then i realized
like
you know i'm gonna i'm gonna go
somewhere and so
you know i
my dad even though my parents were split
my dad was at
every freaking game and he was quite a
ways you know he kind of moved to a
different
town but he came to every game
and yeah i mean my life was was sport
sport and training i mean i loved i
loved
lifting camps like in the summertime
it was every football camp i could sign
up for and honestly my mom's like
you know she was so you know involved
with
with her position at baxter to where
she's like yeah if you want to you know
go somewhere for
a month in the summer do it you know
because i think she probably just
you know was managing plants in puerto
rico
or singapore or wherever the heck you
know she was for her job
so um i just i did not
miss an opportunity to like go to a camp
or something like that
so did you actually get recruited to go
when in your senior year
to go to college yeah there were several
and i i ended up
choosing um i wanted to go back my dad
was moving back to north carolina my
uncle was in north
carolina and one of the
coaches at western carolina played
with my dad and you know we ended up
going out there and it was kind of
a decision that i would be close to to
the dudley family
out that way and i like the idea of like
getting
honestly i never really felt like
that town was home you know and maybe
it's because like you know my parents
were
kind of always split i saw my mom
limited you know when she wasn't
traveling
but we like we traveled away from like
me and my mom were together more when
we'd go places
because she'd say hey you know i've got
a
i've got a meeting in salt lake for two
days do you want to come with me and i'd
say
oh can i go to i've been wanting to
check out snowbird and she's just like
yeah
you know so we'd fly out there and she'd
say the bus will pick you up in the
morning at seven and they'll bring you
back to
you know just make sure you're back here
this time so i just go up and
then i started you know skiing and
shredding
love skiing worked at a little ski hill
up there and skied bumps like all the
time in the
in the winter time and it's cool
so then what happened with college then
so i was going to play football and
like the one thing that i haven't talked
about was back at age
10 when i was a super punk
um my uncle and my grandfather
got me into like hunting deer when we'd
go down to
mississippi we'd go back down there to
see family for thanksgiving
and so you know they were like you know
we need to get you out in the woods and
my grandpa's all you know korean war
veteran and he's like you know we need
to make a man of you because i'm showing
up with
freaking tony hawk haircut and freaking
earrings and
you know stuff like stuff like that
so he's out there you know making me sit
and firing
beds and you know just trying to like
make a man out of this freaking
softy that's coming down and so you know
i got into hunting
and just loved it like it was
and and honestly probably because it was
hard
and it like took a ton of patience and
it was very
different from being able to just screw
off you know and and so it was
it was the first kind of form of
competition
in a way just that it took a lot of
moving parts to be successful so
you know when i got my first deer it was
like
winning my first trophy right i mean i
was totally hooked at how
freaking awesome it was and just seeing
my family like oh my gosh you got a deer
and then we ate it and everything you
know and it was just this
thing so every year for thanksgiving i
was looking forward to going back home
and doing that and i got into bow
hunting i think when i was
the first year i hunted with they gave
me i had a gun
and then um when i was 10
is when i started shooting a bow and bow
hunting
so that was once a year that was
happening
but then i got a little bit better
towards the end of my senior year i was
shooting a
lot more around home like i was
practicing and stuff a lot because again
i had a lot of free time
you know my mom would be gone you had no
homework
yeah no homework if i wasn't like
cutting grass
like you know for five bucks a lawn then
that's what i was doing
but uh i ended up uh
driving down this road i actually had
hurt my knee
so i was i was i moved into college a
little bit early
um and hurt my knee
and then i forget what happened but i
i was at home back by my mom's for some
reason i was just driving around on this
like a back road
and i think i was coming i think i went
to college
yeah i was i moved in i moved in and i'm
talking like
there a week maybe maybe a week and a
half
and you can on a weekend you hurt your
knee at some point yeah
and so you're not really able to play
yeah and so for whatever reason you go
back home
yeah we did some we did some like
run-throughs
i know i did some stuff with like you
know i remember wearing like
pants jersey helmet you know just doing
like dry runs and stuff but i wasn't
i don't i never like hit really hit
helmets you know in college and so it
was the weekend
i went back and saw my mom and then
i drove i think i went up to the ski
hill just to
you know go up there and say hi to some
people that worked up in the summer and
on my way back i took some back roads
back home
and i went by this little town called
ringwood and i saw this sign on the
on the side of the road that just said
archery shoot like
spray-painted on a board and just had an
arrow like pointing that way
so i went down that road and i'm like
what's this all about you know
yeah i had my phone down this road yes
you did yeah
yes you did bro you went down the road
and
i said what's this all about and they're
like oh we got a you know 40 target
course and you know
here's how the scoring works on the
animal you know it's 3d animal targets i
had never seen
3d animal targets i'd always like shot
at bales of hay and stuff like that
so i went out and freaking
halfway through the course i was out of
arrows
i had freaking shot the woods down
and i remember leaving the course
got in my car went back up to wilmot
wisconsin
which was where the ski hill was but
there's also a ganner mountain outlet
store there
went in and bought more arrows like in a
rage
and went back to finish the because i
didn't want to not
finish the course so i bought more
arrows to go back to finish
by the time i like finished everything
was pretty much done
and they were having the award ceremony
and the guys that were
up on that podium all had these shirts
that had like their local
shop on the shirt so i remember this was
on a sunday
and on monday morning
like when they i think they opened at
one o'clock but at
one o'clock i was at that shop just like
when are those guys coming in that you
know won this weekend and
i just started standing there and
watching these people
shoot and ask questions and i was there
a few days just kind of
being a stalker and
and the owner of the archery shop
uh called me to the side said hey kid
what are you what are you doing i said
i'm just
i'm watching i'm watching and he said
well
come in the back room i need you for a
minute he took me in the back room and
he said
i forgot to get this guy's arrows done
he goes have you ever built arrows and i
said
no sir and he goes okay well
here's how you do it and he said you
know you're going to clean this
feather like this then you're going to
put the glue on it you put it in this
clamp and then you stick it down
and he's like you know set this timer
and then move on to this next jig and do
a second arrow and then when you get to
the six you can go back to the first if
the timer's gone off you rotate it
and so i just sat in this room and
fletched this guy's arrows
and then kind of came out and i said
like
i got him you know so he came out and
gave the guy his arrows and
um the guy just said all right
do those ones and he had just this
buckets of arrows that
needed to get done so i just started
fletching arrows and then the next day's
like have you ever worked on a bow and i
said no i haven't he's like all right
well
let me show you how to change a string
and you know and then he's like hey if
you know if they're if these bows are
here for maintenance you know here's the
checklist you gotta you know clean these
axles you gotta wax a string and
melt it in with this and just started
showing me and honestly after
probably two weeks of doing that
um i i ended up telling the guy i said
hey am i gonna get a paycheck
and he's just like i remember the guy's
name was mike
donovan some people in the archery
industry like old timers they still
remember him because he was
he was a pretty hardcore uh archery
manager at the time
but he goes you can't put value on what
i'm teaching you right now
i remember i'm like no sir you can't but
i can't put gas in my tank
you know with experience so he uh he's
like i'll give you
410 an hour and i'm just like oh yeah
you know i was freaking pumped and i
remember
going home to my dad and i went to my
dad
to north carolina well my dad at that
time i think was
yeah he was still in rockford illinois
and i remember telling my
dad um
hey i'm not going to go to college to
play
ball because i'm
you know i've got this archery thing
going and it's
it's a good it's good he's like you're
like dad
four ten an hour i did he because i
remember
you know again he's always been super
logical
and he's also like tried to not he never
really told me like
at that point he had never said like
what's wrong with you or
you know that's a terrible decision but
in that instance he's like
i i really feel like you need to make
your own decisions and you need to know
like what to do he said but
i have to say i think this is a terrible
decision
and uh i think for my 40th birthday he
wrote me this really long
birthday card and like in there he said
he's like you could have not
done a better job of proving me wrong
because he's like he goes
he goes i can't believe i can't believe
what you've done in like
22 years type thing you know hey what
when you went to that uh 3d shoot for
the first time on the
on the side of the road or whatever what
do you think it
what feeling did you have what was it
that just freaking was like this is it
i uh yeah like i listened to
ted nugent on rogan and like he gives
some crazy description of like launching
an arrow it's all poetic and everything
yeah
is that what you you were just like no
never had that
for me it was
i couldn't like the fact that i knew it
that
was a that showed me how inferior i was
with a bow and arrow and i loved hunting
and it showed me that there was
every person that was in that parking
lot was a lot better than me
and that was a problem and and that a
hundred percent was
you know i had to go to the shop i had
to learn
and then it's like i'm not gonna leave
until i beat these guys
these guys that are winning like i need
to beat them
and then once i did that it was you know
i remember i
did really well did well fast
and i remember going to a shoot that was
about
45 minutes away to the north and i
remember going in there and my name was
like
written down on a piece of paper that
was like at this registration desk and
these are
rinky-dink like local shoots you know
i don't know if like you have like local
surf tournaments where it's not like
yeah you know so i just said
oh what's up with that name you got
right there and they're like oh
uh this guy is supposed to be a serious
cheater
so when he comes we're gonna send
someone out with him
and i go oh well that's me who's coming
and wait so they were thinking this
because you had been doing well in the
yeah
because i kind of came from nowhere so
these these people that
that was their thing um they're just
like where did this guy
come from who who even is he you know
they've never seen me
even at a local club you know because i
was just nothing and then
went as i always do you know oh
i'm not good at this then just like head
first
into the deep end like were you shooting
arrows at night waking up in the morning
shooting arrows
like you just full on full-on obsession
immediately
yeah yeah like
you know had to
like sat around after tournaments and
would like
take down courses for places if they'd
give me a target
so i'd have another target you know or
you know i would freaking cut grass or
clean the bottoms of people's boats or
whatever so i could buy another target
and then
you know i had to have an entire range
to practice on
and then it just you know and then i
wanted like a colored target bow
and then it just it's just like it's me
it's just me it's
who i am all the time i just you know i
had to like
i had to get good at it but then there
came a point where
um and actually at that tournament was
kind of a turning point because
this is the cheater one yeah so i went
out did
i ended up winning that tournament and
they had someone like writing score
and i said um i go well that was kind of
nice just having someone else keep score
i'm like
hopefully keep score for these other
guys that have a problem
you know because it's called like pencil
pushing you know
and they just said well if you don't
want to deal with that you could always
go to nationals where there's two score
keepers
and so i'm just like where's that so
then
i went to the national triple crown and
slept in the back of my truck and you
know
shot at that and sucked at it horribly
but then the next year you know i
instead of going like two i went to
all of them drove to all of them
and just got better and got better and
then
within like five years i was at a level
that was
you know that i was happy with but i was
also still refining it you know just
there's
that's what's cool about archery is i
think the reason i'm still doing it is
because
you know i still find if i'm not
centered then it shows so it's hard like
you're never going to have a perfect
game to where you could just back away
and know that like
okay that was a cinderella story i've
done because
you can go have a perfect round but then
an hour later you gotta shoot another
one yeah
yep yep how do you cheat in archery
well i mean there's just there's groups
where you know if at like a local
tournament they're not going to send a
scorekeeper out so let's just say like
we all went out with our wife
there's definitely people that you know
they would shoot down there and score
like an eight but they'd just like ride
a ten
meanwhile like the wives and kids are
just like not giving a crap about what's
going on but then you just
turn in your scorecard and you know this
but once you get into like the
professional events there's
two people that keep score the majority
of the group has to
agree on the arrow call
and then if there's ever a divide then
you call an official scorekeeper to come
and call it
which is kind of a big reason why i
liked
progressing because once i was shooting
like
internationally you know they had like
you couldn't even have an arrow judge
that was from your country so if you
you know it's like if an american needed
an arrow call
someone would come over like an official
judge from another
country would come over because
obviously now there's teams competing
against teams so
you know these judges had schooling on
how to call an
arrow and you know stuff like that so
how does that go like you know i enter
the tournament
and then what i just shoot them at my
own pace kind of thing
and keep my own score i think what's
good what might be confusing you echo is
like
the first tournaments that he's talking
about are just like
kind of like local it'd be like you're
going to fail
it's like going to like a little jiu
jitsu tournament somewhere and there's
not like judges
you know what i'm saying we're a
jiu-jitsu tournament like an in-house
jiu-jitsu tournament
like when you have like at victor you
have an in-house jiu jitsu tournament
there's no like
escalating the called or that the point
keep
you know you're like hey man you lost
whatever you did good someone could be
like oh yeah
no you're not getting points on that
sweep so these are just like local
little tournaments
where you go out and you score and
you're like you know my my eight's
pretty close to a ten
and i'm going to give it to myself so
there's no one watching
yeah because it's just you just because
you're like on a path through
like through this course to where it's
not like
golf like professional golf there'd be
like a crowd
following like those leaders through
that course
which in professional archery like that
happens
um and then once you get into shooting
in the finals a lot of times it's like
on monitors and everything so obviously
people can
see on a big screen where the arrows are
landing
so i mean probably the same in
competitive like rifle and stuff like
that yeah it's the same in competitive
anything
like really like when you're at a local
tournament or
whether it's freaking bowling you know
like over the line
you know market zero they're just having
an argument you know it's like you can
cheat
and then but then you turn in like a
score card or something
so when you shoot you you score however
many points you and then you write it on
the card and then you know what to the
next target or yeah
and then you go through a course yeah
and at the end you turn in the card
yeah it'd be like you playing cribbage
with someone at home and then also
you're like
oh i won they're like well wait a minute
i
dude we have to be at least even you're
like no i was keeping score like here's
how it looked
or you go to vegas and play cribbage and
like it you know
everything you're doing is under you
know a magnifying glass type thing
so what point did you make the
transition or was it the whole time from
like
3d archery to target archery um
i got i honestly got a little bit bored
in 3d archery pretty fast
and part of the part of what i didn't
like about it
there was just i felt like i was going
to the same places all the time
because there was i'm trying to think i
turned pro in 98
so by like 2003 i just felt like
i would land know how to get to the
shoot without even
like wouldn't even need to like look at
a map i'd just know where to go and then
you go to these courses and it would be
like
well a lot like you know we shot big sky
together
you know for the total archery challenge
and
we've shot the same course because
it ends in a good place you know
um but there's certainly targets that
you
like you would be like oh last year we
had the white bunny right here
you know and so it got to the point
where it was like that i was going to
places where i'm
you know 26 or 30 weekends a year i'm
traveling
to to do tournaments and
it just felt super repetitive and in the
end
i realized there's probably
10 or 12 people that are fully capable
of winning
like any weekend but it's almost like if
you have that same tournament
you know two consecutive days over and
over and over again
there's probably like five that would
win it
differently each of those times and
i don't know it just came it it just got
to be
stale for me i got you know i just
really got bored with that
and it got to the point where i
pretty much had it set in my mind of i'm
a target archer to be a better bow
hunter
you know and that was like my mentality
is i was just
i could barely be focused by the time
the world championships rolled around in
august
i barely cared because i just wanted to
be hunting in september
and you know that the hunting was always
the focus for me
and it was like i almost i got more out
of it
so you know i just eventually
i did what i needed to do in competitive
archery to like help me build a platform
to where i really wanted to go which is
i've always liked to
to coach you know and and
and i've always liked really good
coaches
you know i've liked i'm the type of
person where i liked coaches that like
honestly that like yelled at me and were
like harry's head coaches were
you know sharon said that guy's just a
dick like i'd
i kind of think i would love that guy
you know
if he like grabbed my face mask and he's
yelling at me
like it would make me do better on the
next play
whereas now as an adult
i've learned there's certain people
where if you did that
you're not getting that result freaking
breakdown
yeah so so wait a second so
you're doing the target archer thing and
then oh sorry you're doing the 3d thing
then you start doing target archery like
and like at what point are you part of
team usa and you're putting on the team
usa stuff
dang man i don't like have my whole life
outlined so
um i had retired i you know i got sick
of it i retired
and i was working at a bow manufacturer
you know
didn't go back to that but at 18 um you
know i started working for this archery
shop
didn't like the one-on-one experience
that that archery shop owner was giving
people buying new equipment
and i was spending a lot of time with
people and so i got called in and he
told me
you know hey do not spend that much time
with people when they buy new gear
if they go over 15 minutes they need to
be paying
coaching time per hour and i just said
well this you know no one was in the
shop and i didn't have anything else to
do why wouldn't we help this guy out
and i remember he said well
if you want to run a business that way
then you need to go
start your own archery shop so i just
thought
oh okay and so i went and started my own
archery shop
um about 45 miles away that it was
actually
our my family had a had a horse ranch in
southern wisconsin at the time my mom
and my sister
so i ended up building a pole building
there and starting my own shop
and that was the same time i started
shooting professionally
and then got offered a job from a bow
manufacturer to
move to northern wisconsin to you know
come in as like an early sales rep so i
ended up
working for this bow company and
competing
so i mean my life was archery 20
hour archery 20 hours a day and then i
kind of got burned out with it
and i found myself liking going
fishing or going hunting or just doing
something that wasn't like
training training training for archery
and then
um i had retired for like a few months
retired from i kind of just said i'm not
gonna shoot professionally anymore
and i just stepped away and i was doing
some coaching at
like i was doing a lot for some
different like youth camps and stuff
and i remember
seeing another archer at like
at a trade show and he's and he said
something about
you know i heard you're not shooting
anymore and i just said yeah i got
you know bored with it and i kind of
just jokingly said
you know maybe i'll come over to target
archery because 3d archery is all
like foam animal targets with molded in
scoring rings um ranging from you know
the size of a dime
you know up to like what would be
considered just the vitals which would
be bigger
but then target like a dinner plate size
yeah but then
for target archery there's several
different formats and that's
bull's-eyes you know with scoring rings
but
a lot of different games to play right
you know there's tons of different
formats of shooting at a bullseye target
different distances
some you don't know the distance you
have to estimate it
some have like multiple size faces some
are
certain amount of arrows at this
distance certain amount of that distance
that distance but
anyway i i said to this guy um yeah
maybe i'll just
i don't know maybe i should just try
target archery and i remember um
he looked at me goes come on in the
water's fine
oh famous last words and that was it
i was like okay when's the first
tournament
and the first he told me the first
tournament was um
at the arizona cup in
uh at the ben avery did you ever shoot
at the ben avery center in arizona
uh so that was the first one and ended
up
you know ended up in the metal you know
gold medal match with that guy
at that event with that guy with that
guy
in your first event yeah that one
and i showed up like everything i had
was wrong
because you know there's i don't know
how to describe it it'd be like if you
did you know tactic you know tactical
competition
and then someone asked you to go to a
sniper event and then you like
showed up with your m4 or something you
know i don't know it's
it's mission specific yeah they're both
archery but one of them
has like you're standing around you got
more time to shoot or whatever
less time to shoot your gear is going to
be different the whole nine yards yeah
so i remember
uh right before that metal match
and as it happened i was low in the
brackets he was
you know very high in the brackets but
we were on opposite ends of the brackets
and so at this center you know there's
uh
you know it's let's say it's a hundred
yards wide
i was like at this end and he was at
that end
and as you shoot against someone and go
through the brackets
you just come to the middle so like
when i won my semifinal match i remember
like looking over and i see you know i
saw that he won
and i'm like okay here we go and he
comes over and he said man
he's like how i see he said how are you
dealing with it and i said
dealing with what and he said well i've
won this
nine times and you know everyone wants
me to lose and he said so i can imagine
like
you know the pressure you're feeling you
know
being that guy and i said man i see it
the other way
and he goes what do you mean i said dude
i'm out here
my equipment's a joke i said i'm out
here i'm a 3d shooter i got the wrong
freaking bow i got the wrong arrows
never even shot this far and i said and
i'm getting ready to roll up on you
and i said and i'm like you won this
nine times
and honestly i could see like that was
you know
that cracked and i ended up getting the
gold medal there
oh you so the first time you won it yeah
that's freaking nuts so then i guess
that pretty much kicked off your
target archery yeah yeah so we um
there was a lot of like that kicked off
my target archery so i did
one type then i did another type and
then i went into field archery which is
my favorite
it's kind of like the tack but with with
different size bullseyes and granted you
know in the pro class these guys aren't
missing
it's like you need perfect scores you
know you really do
and i went to this field um
this field tournament and just sucked at
it because half of it is marked
the other half is unmarked meaning
unknown distance
unknown distance which in archery is a
problem if you don't know the distance
because your arrow is
way slower than a bullet so um
i wasn't good at it and ended up buying
myself an entire field round
and like you know reading up on you know
target faces and then ended up
figuring out a mathematical formula to
estimate distances
using like the circles in my scope and
the circles of the bullseye
so i would like frame the side of my
scope to the edge of the target and then
i memorized where my
center dot would be based on the rings
and just memorize a gauging
distance gauging formula which is what
everybody does but most people
keep it secretive on how you know what
their system is
but because the targets are all
regulation they have to be the same size
you can figure it out
so then um i got good at that
you know and and that was kind of my
favorite and then you know made
made a team made a u.s team and then
went over
and competed i think my first
international tournament was in croatia
and you know freaking just loved
meddled there and you know loved
freaking
when they pulled that american flag up
and like you got to hear your anthem it
was just like
okay this is freaking this
is awesome yeah and so how long did that
career run for
that career ran until the archery
world archery decided to do a world cup
and they decided to make the world cup
um so at the world cup
i think only two at the year at the time
it was maybe two or three
archers you had to be on on a team um
would shoot in the world cups but
whoever the finalists the top four were
at the end of the world cup then you had
to go to the world cup finals
which was like a big thing and
they decided to add one tournament and
move the world cup
finals it was like september 15th
this year and so i remember
um world archery telling me
you know hey if you're going to shoot on
the world cup team
you have to give us the commitment that
you will not only do
all four world cups but if you make the
world cup final that you
also participate in the world cup final
otherwise
we're going to find someone that will
you know because we don't want to like
end up making a final and then someone
don't can't get off work or whatever and
so
you know as in september i just said i
am not competing in archery in september
and for everyone that doesn't know
september is
freaking prime that's haunting season
yeah that's when you you're only
thinking about
you're thinking about one thing and one
thing only yes
just freaking hunting that's it that's
it
and so you kind of walked yeah i walked
mm-hmm now and i walked for i walked
from there and then
you know i ended up business-wise uh
started consulting went out on my own
started consulting
you know started a family sharon and i
you know it was like i wanted to be home
more
a lot more people could come to me you
know for coaching and stuff
and i was i was coaching around the
world at that time
uh but yeah just you know life changes
you become
30 you know close to 30 it's just you
know i didn't
i just didn't see the future that i
wanted just being a target archer my
whole life you know and i think
you know we talked about this i think
some fighters are in that same
position of like yeah you love it and
you know you can go win like fight of
the night and you could
make a pretty good paycheck for that
time but the reality is like
you're one or two fights a year that
you're gonna make a paycheck
at they're gonna make 98
of the rest of your life not as you know
not what you could make for it if you
had a different focus
so you know i just i just focused on
something else now
from a business perspective did you have
the vision
of like knock on archery because
essentially what you do is
freaking give away an incredible amount
of knowledge and information
and instruction that's what you do that
did you know from the beginning hey
listen if i just give this stuff away
then people will you know want to buy
some of the stuff that i recommend
utilize some of the equipment that i
make is that did you have that vision or
did it just start to happen
it's hard to say if i was in a different
position then if i would have felt that
way
because i don't feel like i'm greedy
i feel like the better i do for myself
in other avenues of life the more i can
give back to my sport
and i want to because you know i feel
like hey i'm doing fine
and you know and i want to help other
people be better
but the truth of the matter is you know
when you're
in your 20s making 30 grand a year
or 50 grand a year at your job and
you're trying to go to tournaments to
win an extra 10 on the weekend
and you're just putting a lot of time in
and you're shooting
20 to 30 000 arrows you know a year
and living out you know sharing rooms
with people and stuff like that like
there's a lot of stepping stones that
have to there's a lot of sacrifices you
make
before it gets to the point where it's
like you know
you could offer all that for free but
once
once the community and i and by that i
mean
you know i refer to them as the knock on
nation once
once we had a pedestal to where we were
able to
to deliver out information and our
community
came in and started supporting
that initiative then it allows me
you know the more people support like
either things that we offer at the store
or let's say i do a training series
and there's a training series that helps
someone do better but maybe there's a
product that we have
as our business you know that'll be in
there and i know
not everyone's going to buy it but if
someone does
you know if they really like that series
and it was worth
you know 100 bucks to them i would
rather
instead of them paying a subscription to
like support us with
you know a product that we have that
i that i personally believe in for that
particular thing now everyone has their
has their preference but i don't think i
could have done
it that way to begin with even though
when i was
kind of hustling and doing what i could
to like
you know build i would always go
and do youth camps or go do christian
camps and do stuff like that for free
like i always did that i always worked
with
you know the kids after the tournament
or
um you know it kind of got to the point
where
i told sponsors especially when i went
out and i was kind of consulting
i told sponsors i would like to travel
through europe and go to every archery
club
and do a seminar but
you know i can't pay for it myself would
you you know would you like to be the
one that
sponsors the event in dusseldorf you
know and if so
send me 25 of your hats and some key
chains or whatever and that's what we'll
put on everyone's seat that
you know that comes and so we just do
these tours where i'd have magazine
editors drive
me all around europe and every day was a
different stop
you know just kind of like a band every
day was a different archery club stop
teach archery and then you know do it in
the end
i made something more because you know
the sponsors were
paying something and you know getting
some exposure from it and then i also
did a lot of writing
you know i did a lot of a lot of
written coaching first because like
getting your foot in the door when you
don't
technically have like a name for
yourself yet is
a little bit of a struggle but i saw
a lot of magazines needing fresh content
and
so you know i just started writing so
from like 2 000
i would say from 2005
to probably 2 000
or 14 i was i wrote for like
seven different languages i'd probably
do about 250 pages a year
just in articles and honestly my thing
was i'd send these articles out
i didn't really make hardly anything off
any of the articles
i just always made sure that they used
my photo content
so that you know i was able to give
exposure to the brands that i
represented
and so you know just it's kind of like
the perfect storm of
having enough support to where i could
grow into where i wanted to be and then
you know then
eventually like knock on
knock-ons like evolved originally it was
a tv show
it was just a hunting show but it was a
hunting show that i was very focused on
having educational portions i didn't
like
b-roll in hunting shows you know i
didn't
i always thought there needs to be more
education and how to
and why was this hunt successful or
here's the equipment that i'm taking on
this hunt
you know i changed arrows or changed
broadheads here's the why
you know here's different mistakes you
can make as a bowhunter for shooting
technique so
that was that kind of gave us the
platform to
to create a name for ourself and then
obviously
you know we've just continually built we
meaning
i've only ever done the content the
brand was always sharing
you know the brand and you know knock on
archery.com has
always been sharon um whereas
you know i really don't like that side
of things i just really want to like
i want to teach people from my
experience of of whatever's happening at
the moment
how'd the tv show come about the tv show
came because
one of the companies that i worked for
was an archery company
and so each year they would pick
a certain demographic and tell me to
focus
my initiatives there to grow the brand
and that demographic
so one time it was you know
south africa another time it was like
germany another time it was australia
but it came around to canada and so i
went up and talked to a lot of shops up
there and
said you know hey what do you guys think
about doing like a seminar tour
like what was working for me and other
demographics
because over there people were jumping
on that because no one would travel
over there to do that maybe it's like
that with jiu jitsu if a
if a reputable coach travels to
somewhere where they're never going to
see that person
they it'll sell out you know for sure
versus
in canada they said at the time
canada just got their first outdoor tv
network which was called wild tv
and they had hunting shows but most of
their shows were shows that we had
watched here
five ten years ago and it was just all
the shows domestically were sending all
their repeats up there and just like you
know
just kind of rebranding but then also
like
selling that air time to their sponsors
here like yeah we're also airing
you know 10 times a week in canada
for this or that so when i was up there
the shop said
well i mean we would love to get like
super technical seminars but
what brings people in the doors when the
hunting shows come like if if you're on
a hunting show
there if you're on wild tv we'll
freaking pack the store
so i remember going back to my boss at
the time
who actually works for us now and i told
him i said well
they really said to get the foot in the
door like we need to be
i need to be a show and i had already
done dvds
that were like you know kind of
out of the trunk of your car dvds that i
thought were a little bit of
ahead of their time because i always
said that like
i wanted our hunting show to be like
hunting kind of crashed with
mtv cribs crashed with like rob and big
and so like our first dvds that's what
they were
and so they were to like way faster
paced music
and like way different editing than kind
of like the banjo music
do you put those on youtube i haven't i
need to get you one of those dvds how
come you don't put them on youtube
on your youtube channel people are going
to be amped to watch them now
maybe they i mean looking back it'd be
like you watching yourself on video
10 years ago you'd be like man was i
horrible well you at least got to have
some fun with it before tomorrow oh yeah
i mean like that haircut you posted
prince valentine
that was freaking awesome bro it was
1977. that was what was happening
and i didn't i don't think i even had i
don't think i didn't even think i
thought
you know what i'm saying i didn't think
i thought about like a haircut
i think it was just you know my mom
would come in with a pair of scissors
you know done like i wasn't like do i
need here
for a minute yeah do i need to get a
haircut do i not need you she's just
like that's
it was like that's what's happening
right you don't have
any choice in the matter and didn't care
about it one way that i still
barely care i feel like when we post
this podcast we need to put a thing in
there that says like
unless you're a dork about archery fast
forward to like
the hair moment because like
me talking about my past to me seems
like
i don't know i'd way rather what i
remember about you
the most is like how hard we laugh at
stuff
and you know it's such a different side
than you know kind of like at the
beginning of the thing when you're
reading
you're so serious and awesome at that
like you're the you're the perfect
person to like do voice over work
but i also know like at any given second
if it was just the two of us
you could drop a one-liner in there that
would freaking
bust people up in here yeah
i definitely i mean that's bro yeah
you're right
any of this stuff it's like you're
having fun while you're doing it if it's
not fun to do
then why are you doing it yeah i will
say though like
i like to have fun you like to have fun
but man it's legit when you go into like
kill mode
on a hunt it's freaking like i'm like oh
yeah here it is
you because you go into just like boom
like i could i just see i'm like okay i
gotta hang on because he's freaking
he's going and it's it's legit man
well i think that same thing that's just
inside it's dormant
and i'm pretty i'm pretty like low-key
in docile most of the time
um i feel like that's how i am
naturally but then like certain things
like that
when that moment triggers and it's like
a game face
that's kind of what happened when i
recognized like i wasn't good at archery
you know i realized like you know
i just it's like hyper focused um
and it gets that way with my training
too if i know i'm not
up to par i get very hyper focused on
on just getting better and and training
and i can
kind of just go over the deep you know i
can either be all in or
or totally out which is kind of like
from a target archery point of view
people ask me why i don't compete
i don't have like i don't have a drive
to compete that's not to say if for some
reason
i you know did it accidentally and
i wouldn't get fired up again like oh no
i didn't do that i've seen you do that
where we're
walking down the tack and all of a
sudden someone's like hey dud
i bet i can do this i bet i can hit that
you're like
same thing i'll see your face and i'm
like oh he's about to just 12 ring this
thing
you know because you get in that
competitive mode that happens
you know what i wanted to come back to
and and hey the reason why i think this
stuff is interesting look
i don't think you have to be interested
in archery because you
your your path in life was not normal
right and people look you could have
been talking about someone that was into
spearfishing or someone that was in a
jiu jitsu or someone that was into
anything
to go down the path like you did and
forge your own way ahead and make a life
for yourself
based on doing something that you loved
people could apply that
in any category whether you're into
knitting or whether you're into freaking
uh bowling it doesn't matter so yeah
there's some real
application i guess i should have said
that at the beginning hey if you're
thinking about the way your life looks
especially if you're 20 years old or 25
years old and you're kind of like well
i'm doing this but i don't like it
i mean here you are like going to
college but i don't really want to do
that you know yeah hey
and you've done that multiple times 3d
archery i'm totally into it oh guess
what i'm not really into
that that much into it anymore okay i'm
going to do something else go to target
archery okay
i'm really into that for a while guess
what it's interfering with my hunting
not going to do that anymore now i'm
going to focus on hunting
i'm going to focus on building this
brand i'm going to focus on creating new
products so
all that stuff it may seem mundane to
you
looking back at it but for a normal
person that can take this and apply it
to
you know uh building something creating
something
it's like you've done well not just from
an archery perspective but a business
perspective
in in at the same time so it's real
lessons
one of the lessons i wanted to come back
to because we kind of drifted over it
but
when you were talking about as somewhere
along the way
you realize that you could like freaking
rage
doesn't help right rage doesn't help and
you said you had a coach that was like
hey listen
the arrows that you shot and this is
such an important this again this is a
life lesson
and there's all kinds of things that tie
into life and archery
but the life lesson is like hey you shot
that arrow and you freaking
shanked it right you can blow your next
eight arrows like you can just send them
all out the
freaking you know into a tree somewhere
or you can just be like okay that didn't
doesn't matter can't change it move
forward what was that lesson like who
taught it to you
um an olympic arch an olympic archery
coach
who i'm pretty sure was also a marine i
mean like
you know straight-up marine haircut all
the time but he coached a couple
uh a couple like super high level
uh archers but he was also like he
didn't coach very many people
and he was also you know very
i don't know he was he was very like
stone you know so
you knew if he was there he was there
watching
his few athletes and they like would pay
for him to come
and stuff like that but i remember one
time
i was in a leading group you got peer
grouped and then
the second day your you know like ranks
one two three and four are together on
the target
you know when they shoot through and
then it kind of came down to the last
target
and you know i needed a 12 or something
to make it into the shootoff you know
into the top six
and uh and i missed
you know and i was freaking pissed about
you know like broke my stabilizer over
my knee and freaking
hammer tossed my boat through the woods
type thing
and you know ended up coming back
like with my bow just kind of seeing the
damage i did and
and he came over to me his name was tim
strickland
and he said you know
you could be an amazing archer but he
said
until you start not letting the arrow
that you shoot affect the ones that are
still in your quiver
you never will and he said he goes
do you know a way to get an arrow back
once it's left your bow and i said
what do you mean he goes do you know a
way to get it back other than to
physically go down there and pull it out
of the target like he just did and i
said no sir and he said
well once it's gone it's gone and he
said so
if you make one mistake
don't make the same mistake for every
arrow that's left in your quiver
you know make one pull it you know
pull that arrow out throw it away
whatever you want but there's other
arrows in the quiver that are capable of
doing what you want them to do
and so there's been tournaments where
i've
you know i've actually talked you know
where i
will freaking make a bad shot and then
just look down on my quiver and be like
do any sons of [ __ ] want to go in the
ten ring because
that guy didn't and you know and it was
just like a totally different approach
and mentally it's you know i've
i've totally it it honestly helped me
this was a it's kind of a weird
thing to say but um you know he told me
said you won't figure out how to win
until you learn how to lose
and that was a you know i was
like the rage of losing was overpowering
my ability to perform at my best because
i was
letting you know i was letting those
things happen and then i remember
kind of wanting to get into that a
little more and i read some kind of a
sports psychology book you know i don't
know what it was called
but it said something in there that
this sports psychologist had talked to
like he worked with a lot of high level
pitchers
and he told them that part of their
success was that they had to
be able to accept that there was going
to be an umpire
that would they needed to expect two to
three
bad calls by the umpire every game
and when they got a call that they
didn't think was right
they could just check it off the list of
okay well there was one of them
and so i started doing that too and
started
saying okay when i go to an
international event because
there certainly are judges that call
them
really really tight you know and
they're all looking at them with a
magnifying glass but there's some
like when you'll say like judge and then
you know
some dude comes over that is notorious
like if the
you know when they do their random thing
of like judge so and so go
pull it and then you see him you're like
it's out
because some of you just think like they
think like if
if they can't figure it out themselves
i'm just gonna go over there and look
around at it but i'm calling it out
you know and then there'd be some like
oh yeah i got a chance with this gal
like
you know hey susie how you doing today
but uh yeah learning that you know
learning
learning how to lose because i've lost
way more than i've won
and that you know and that that's a
that's a fact if
you know i you have to figure out a way
to win in life
you know you do have to figure out a way
to win but
if you deal with like being
hyper competitive then you also have to
learn how to lose
otherwise you freaking derail yourself
way more than others can derail you and
i'm convinced that i beat myself
way more than other people beat me and
and most of the things that i've lost at
you know it's like which is why now my
coaching has evolved so much because now
my coaching is so
focused on you know what you execute
within your box
because i kind of got to the point where
i recognized if i make a good shot it's
a 10
that's the highest score on the paper so
if i do that all day no one's going to
beat me
we're tied at the end and if i just keep
doing that until tomorrow
then guess what worst case scenario me
and that other guy are still tied
but if i shoot nines then yeah the other
guy
is already at an advantage so you know
if i focus on just
execution and so once i kind of came to
that
realization of no one can beat me if i'm
executing
if i make a good shot right here i don't
need to see where it lands
because if my sight tapes right and i
trust the equipment that i've got
i know it's in the middle like i know
that but i have to execute here
and so it really got to the point where
i like
i took away my spotting scope to where i
wasn't getting in the habit of
shooting an arrow looking for the result
shooting an arrow looking a result which
is something that even today when i work
with parents
i tell them that there's there's like
parents that at an archery tournament
they sit like front row with a spotting
scope so the kid will shoot and then
they'll be like
at 11 o'clock and then you know and the
kid will shoot and just
turn around to like dad to get
confirmation of
like how that was and so part of the
things when you have that type of parent
is telling them like
listen this kid like they need to
execute
them looking for at you for
you know the result all the time
it it just athletes start to lean on
their coach so much
and that was actually one of the
problems with
some of the people that had that coach
that i talked about
they only did really well when he could
be there with him
because you know he'd be like all right
hey you missed that one
f those guys you know you're good you're
the freaking
you know and they had to have that that
that
continual like affirmation
whereas honestly from my life i feel
like most of it i was
alone you know in regards to like
i like training alone you know honestly
i like archery too because it's a
singular sport
so if i train
and if i prep then i'm ready
and it's in my hands same with hunting
you know same way with hunting if i you
know i've had hunts where
i've had a lot of distractions and i
threw my stuff in a case that
you know the day before and went and you
know missed a couple shots and was just
like
enraged but then i also thought like
yeah dude you didn't prep you did no
homework
you know that's what happens so i feel
like
because i've had to train that way and
even
even when i lift you know i love lifting
by myself
versus like going to somewhere where
people distract me
i just feel like you know i've
i know that if i put in the work
then at that point it's it's really on
me
not on someone else and like when i told
you we sucked at football
you know there was a couple people like
you know
like jason who knew their role and knew
their position
and other people's position and they
would cover for people that maybe didn't
do something right
but there's also three cores of the team
that didn't so
in high school what's hard is i don't
feel like
anyone really prepped as hard as me in
that
because i honestly like put no effort
anywhere else
you know whereas they probably had lives
and maybe you know actually got good
grades and stuff
but i think that's why archery's been
so awesome to me is because you know the
harder i've
pushed the harder i've pushed at it and
the more i've put into it
like it's not like weight lifting where
you plateau
i haven't found a plateau yet like i can
make a target further and i can suck
again
or you know you know there's just or i
can try
a different species or a different you
know
climate or a different time of year and
it's a whole new
challenge like it's a clean slate and
then you're you know
trying to formulate a plan and map out a
plan of how do i
you know how do i like win this
challenge i i i was at uh you and i were
at tac
the first time we did tech and like i
was
like feeling pretty good and i'm like
you know you're like bro you're freaking
this is awesome you're doing great
and we're getting through the course a
little bit and then man
then i just i i like hit a branch right
and it was a little situation where you
said step
back and you meant back behind me but i
thought you meant back
away from the target and so i like
didn't it even makes sense to me what
you said so i didn't listen to you which
is a mistake
so i just cracked off this around and
this thing just freaking
just banged into a
tree in in everyone on that mountain
everyone like it sounded like you hit
someone's
like door with a mac like with the
microphone on the back side
and and this is what i saw earlier you
know you're saying like hey you know
what somebody grabs me by the face mask
and just like are you going to get this
[ __ ] together right now like
that's what you want and then but like
i've
i've done that like when i was in the
when i was in the seal teams and i was
teaching like i would be you know i'd
have some guy that i'd be like hey man
if i freak out on this guy he's gonna
freak out
and he's gonna collapse and break down
mentally and i got someone else where is
like if i don't get their attention
you know some guy might pull aside and
say hey listen man think about what's
going on another guy may be like hey
you need to think about what's going on
and you got to figure out what
methodology you're going to use
yeah so what's what what's interesting
for me is when you're coaching me
like i know what you're doing i know
that i go oh he
he's trying to get me to chill out
because like on that one you were like
you're like hey man hit you hit that
limb up there you know it's just trying
to say but
you know you said you know knock another
one knock take a step back knock another
one i was like cool
and i was like he's just trying to get
me to chill out so i don't freak out
because i just
freaking t-boned a tree and and like i
know what you're doing but as echo
charles says sometimes to me
he knows what i'm doing when i'm talking
to him about stuff he's like i know what
you're doing
guess what still works yeah it still
works to be like hey
here's what's going on man just just
back off a little bit or dude you're
freaking out
you're not you know how to do this like
those kind of coach and also being like
hey get over here like hey you need to
move down
like those kind of things are important
so for you as a coach the way you read
and i've watched now i've watched you
coach a bunch but like attack you'll sit
there
like we'll sit there at a place at one
of the targets and you'll just like
watch
four or five groups shoot and so i just
sit there and watch you coach them you
know and i'll
listen to what you're saying and you i
can tell that you're going you're
reading people
you know and going oh this person needs
confidence or
this person needs to think through needs
to slow things down or this person's
getting freaking all
all target fixated at the last second
and they're cracking the round off
so you're reading them and then you're
applying the right coaching technique
to what's going on in their head and
that's freaking
that's just like that's why honestly to
me
your whole life the number one thing for
me when i look at you is like coach
like that's the the highest thing that i
look at you i was like man that guy's a
look he's a good archer he's a good
hunter he's a badass athlete but man
he's a
freaking dialed in coach
it's what i'm passionate about like
especially
you know with honestly rogan
introducing me to andy like i think was
really the thing that started everything
down the path of now
how many military guys that i've been
able to get into
and gals get into archery um
and you know i love that because
there's so many things that are there
and
especially with team guys
you know whether it's you know whether
it's you know army or
you know it it really doesn't matter
but if if if they've been some type of a
team or like special forces
they just you know they're good students
and they're hyper critical of themselves
now granted some of them are like
i got this and yeah once they realized
no i just made an ass on myself they'll
they'll listen
but even if they don't listen right
there by the next time they talk to you
they've a hundred percent you know went
crazy about
trying to apply that you know ever the
work ethic
is very it's like the perfect formula
for a coach
you know is is all those guys and every
every one of them that i've introduced
it to so far has
needed has really needed archery
as i don't know like like you said it's
like a quiet
it's like a quiet form of what you used
to do you know
well what it is really to me it's a new
mission
like you you spend your whole life with
a mission
with like something that you know that
you're focused on
and then one day you wake up like you
retire or you get out
the mission's gone like you can't have
it anymore and look you can try and hang
on
onto it you can try and freaking relive
those things in your head but
that's not gonna be that's not going to
work out yeah because it's not there
anymore
and that's that's a shitty reality to
face like when i had to clea when my
when i retired and then i went and
cleaned out my cage
and i spent most of my career within
like a
300 yard radius like seal team one
seal team three single team seven i was
at steel team two in virginia beach for
for a little while but most of it you
could throw a football to everywhere i
was so when i was
19 years old i was walking up the steps
of seal team one fast forward
20 24 years and i'm 200 yards away
not even i'm 100 yards away cleaning out
my gear locker
for the last time and it's gone and all
that my whole life
what everything i cared about the only
thing i ever knew is gone
and look i look back at it if i can help
out in any way and i
go talk to the teams that's cool but
that's not my mission anymore
and so this happens to guys and and they
get out and they don't have a mission
anymore so all of a sudden you go
hey man here's a freaking bow and arrow
it's a primitive
tool that you use to hunt [ __ ]
and you can get good at it and and the
the the fundamentals are similar you
know the fundamentals are similar
and like when you taught me for the
first time andy was sitting there
translating he's like hey what he means
is frontside focus
hey what he means is he's easy you know
uh just
squeeze the trigger he was translating
me for me military stuff and i was like
oh god
got it got it yeah and you know andy i
mean andy's a good example of
him just being like oh cool i got a new
mission now here's what i can do
and and look andy of course andy has a
ton of other things going on in his life
and he's got
freaking parachuting and uh jiu jitsu
now he's totally obsessed with jiu jitsu
which is freaking awesome
so so people find new missions but this
is a good one it's a good one because
there's so many similarities
gear prep right when you're in the seal
teams you're freaking obsessed with gear
prep you're figuring out well the best
way to carry things the best way to do
things
and you're like okay i want to be ready
for this i want to be ready for this
operation
right i got to be in good physical shape
i got to be able to like
clear my mind when shit's going sideways
and be like all right
what's happening right now so all those
things are
are so similar and i know that you spent
i guess was andy the first like vet that
you worked with
probably that i mean
probably not i guess but yeah it was
the first one where i was where i was
mentally really ready for that
i think i was on a different like pull
position like i was at a different stage
and it it honestly it meant more you
know
i was going to say with andy like andy
what may have been different
is that andy was like what is that
saying about like when
when the when the student is ready the
master will appear
like i i don't know if you could have
found someone that was more ready
yeah to like pick up this stuff and
start going
you know and so that's probably why it
left an impression on you
damn sure left an impression on andy
because this this dude's totally
obsessed you know
so and it's awesome and you know what's
funny about it
well andy's freaking hilarious you want
to like when you talk about like oh
jocko you make some good one-liners
hanging out like i can listen to andy
just all day long and
and what's really funny to me is like
how he
the way he handles uh uh like mistakes
is he just hammers himself he's so
freaking
hilarious he leaves no room for someone
to make fun of him
because if you don't if you don't fire
off within three seconds yeah
yeah yeah he's freaking classic classic
yeah and that's the kind of thing is
when you know when
when you go out it gives you a mission
now you got your friends with you
you know now you're like okay cool now
we're and we're doing things like what
you do in the seal teams guess what
if if andy and i are on a pistol range
and we're shooting together
like he's gonna be making fun of me
right i'm gonna i'm gonna shank some
round off or whatever
need a mag change in the middle what i
didn't need or i'm gonna do something
stupid
yeah and he's gonna it's gonna it's
gonna be fun and you know what it's
gonna make me better
yeah it's going to make me better and
that's another thing i noticed at tac
like the amount of vets
that were up there yeah it's freaking
awesome it's awesome and guys coming up
to me
and telling me like bro you know i
started this i started this
this is what i'm doing and these are
guys that freaking you know
two years ago whatever when they got out
of the marine corps after six years or
after eight years or after
18 years they didn't have a mission
anymore
and now all of a sudden they're freaking
jocked up they got their gear on their
showed me their freaking range finder
and they're pumped
man they're pumped yep and so the fact
that you've
sort of opened up this uh opportunity
for so many guys
to start going down the path it's
man it's so beneficial to dudes yeah
that's freaking awesome
and it's there also comes a point in
time where you wanna
like i'm fortunate that i can pick and
choose what i'm doing right now
and so i really want to pick and choose
things that's
rewarding to me and hopefully that's not
you know
selfish but there's also like
i don't know there's there's people that
i work with
where i know this person could live on
this planet
a lot longer because they have a new
focus right now
and you know and archery's changed their
life totally
and what's cool about it is you don't
have to be
in like perfect physical shape too so i
mean there's times where people
get into archery and they're kind of a
little bit lost you know
maybe you know maybe they're not as in
shape as they were
or whatever but that's what's cool about
it is it's not age specific
and it's you know if you can pull it
back you can do it
and i think the natural progression is
you pull it back
and you know maybe you're not good and
then you get a little better and then
you know there's a ton of people now
that are just for a better
food source alternative they're
open-minded
hunting if it's can you know in their
minds
fair chase which you know bow hunting
you know
kind of lowers that boundary for people
to where they're like okay if i'm going
to put in all this work and do it
i'm totally cool you know eating this
thing or killing it or whatever
but then once you take that step you
realize
oh this is a whole different kind of
hard because now you're dealing with
in my opinion some of the animals are
just so much smarter
than other things you could roll up on a
merc right
i mean they're they're freaking keyed up
you know
because i remember uh
andy and i were on something where it
was it was
it was a pretty tough like
it was kind of a little bit of a miracle
that we pulled off this stock and
jack something i don't know what it was
but um
i remember saying like you know
doesn't seem like it'd be that hard to
kill a person and he's just like
dude because it is
not this hard at all
he's like he goes all of us would be
he's like you know he's like a lot of us
would be
you know at a totally different level if
we had to learn this way first
he's like it he goes if if everyone had
this
background prior to going into the teams
he's like
it would be it would be insane no it'd
be
very beneficial very beneficial there's
so many things that you've got to think
about that are
the exact same you know the well with
elk the only thing that's not the same
with elk is smell
like like although if you talk to some
of the vietnam guys
they're like oh the vc or the nva would
smell you
yeah and so if you and they could smell
that they could smell them too
so maybe we need to just account for
everything well now with dogs
like what i told andy was i said listen
you know if
if i knew there was someone coming to
jack me you know i would definitely have
at least a dog you know i would
definitely have dogs around because
obviously dogs could smell too
you know if you train them on something
you know specific time
type of gear or something like that it
would be an advantage
but i've actually talked to um
well one of the guys that we're with
tonight
he's actually hooking me up with some of
the guys that are going to do some of
the training
down in lanai for the sniper training
um they're doing a couple team things
there and so he had asked me if i wanted
to go down just to
to teach some navigation of like instead
of
learning the long distance aspect to
like
make some competitions on the closest
shot to where they you know to where i
would
assess their choice of that navigation
and like what they could do different to
where it's like okay we know how you how
far you can shoot something from
now you know who can jack something at
a yard or whatever you know yeah it's uh
it's totally different to have to get
within you know
50 yards or something that's just
freaking crazy yeah it's
it's crazy to think that way whereas
with a rifle you know you can be
i mean at least 500 yards you can be 500
yards and be like
you know we're good i got this i was
so we went surfing yesterday at least
yeah we went surfing yesterday and uh i
was just paused
that bad well actually no i pause for a
second to think to myself did he surf or
not and the fact of the matter is you
did surf
you did surf you paddled on the waves
you caught the waves and you stood up
that's why paul's like wait did he surf
yes you did
you caught multiple waves you paddled
into them yourself
and then you stood up and rode the waves
that's what surfing is
so you did we did surf yesterday and i
know you'd only been one other time
which was the last time you went was was
a little bit more
at the pier yeah it's at the pier and
it's a it's a much more forgivable
sort of like easier step like we
where yesterday that's like you can't
push yourself into those waves you can't
touch the bottom and be like oh i got
this
you have to actually surf where we
served yesterday you actually have to
surf
but when we were when we were going out
we were with josh
and i was sort of like you know i'm just
going to let jock because
like i i don't wanna i didn't wanna be
telling you things and josh telling you
things and you're sitting there
freaking got two people telling you [ __ ]
to do and it's just too much right yeah
so i was just kind of do it i was just
kind of
going and but man as i was going down
there was like
before we even got in the water there
was 97 things i wanted to tell you like
hey man you got to watch out for this
this thing over here
this path over here you got to watch
here's the lineup here's where the
here's where the uh the channels are
like this is where you want to sit
here's what you want to watch
like i had 97 before we even got in the
water that's before we got in the water
and i'm not you know if you're
at a at a freaking black belt level
in archery like i'm not that i'm not at
that highest level of surfing
and i was like man imagine how many
things were going through your head
as you're watching me like a freaking
monkey with a damn
bow just thinking all right with a
50-foot surfboard
yeah yeah i mean it was just like the
amount of things that
that that you don't know about surfing
the amount of things that i don't know
about archery and about hunting and
about scent
and about terrain and about the way the
freaking animals react to this and
different animals react a different way
and there's like so much to learn
it's freaking crazy yeah it's crazy
it's hard as a coach because a lot of
times you forget more than you
like you don't know what you should be
talking about until
you realize like oh oh yeah and you gave
me like there were several of those
yesterday
yeah the worst one was what you told me
when we were on the deck
like watching we were like watching
you're like yeah i meant to tell you
when you were like
you see how all the waves are coming in
right there like off that set
like that's why josh and i when we're
done we would go around those to like
loop back and he's like you know you
just kept going straight back up the gut
yeah and he's like i was just waiting
for that board to like freaking t-rex
your face
and meanwhile i'm like bro that would
have been something like when we were
standing
up on the top looking down if you would
have said like hey you see how
all those waves break like this so when
you
get your set and you ride that out you
know looping behind that
so you're not like freaking how is full
blown like doing buds training
them on their freaking head for freaking
like
eight minutes what happened to dudley oh
he's he's in the impact zone
just getting hammered but but you did
get up like while we were surfing you
know
you did surf and and to me that's a
testament to you know like
being athletic and be being able to
actually
you're really your first day out to go
paddle into waves and stand up that's
not easy to do
now josh hall did make you a freaking
basically an aircraft carrier
it's freaking massive yeah 6
and it's like over four inches thick
and 24 inches which
anyone that's a surfer is hearing these
numbers going damn that is an actual
aircraft
but that's what a perfect platform and
plus your how much do you weigh
240. oh yeah like that's a different
level you need a big-ass board
and it looks like echo charles yes sir
what's up with your surfing career
uh minimal at best we'll see how come
i don't know there's no tangible reason
i mean i guess if i search my
soul you know i did bodyboarding
sponging as
it was sponsoring you know for the most
of my
adolescent life and then yeah how did
you not
how did you not like say oh wouldn't it
be cool to stand up on this thing and
ride this wave and
glide through the ocean
yeah i don't know it's just one of those
things you know like
where i grew up on the south side of
kauai they're actually no they're
surfing but they
i grew up at the beach like literally
grew up at the beach
and then again you're saying this like
this is some sort of a weird way that
you
wouldn't be surfing but you're like no
no i grew up at the beach
yeah exactly right but if you're wrong
if you understand the progression just
naturally kind of growing up there you
go you're swimming
you know in the baby pond at plato beach
and then you're like okay then you're
kind of body surfing a little bit then
you're boogie boarding bodyboarding
sponging
you know yeah and then yes exactly and
then you start to go surf and
and there's a there's a how should i say
a geographical element
to it as well you're literally in the
baby pond then you're outside the baby
pond
and then the surfing waves and the
surfing spots those are
out so you always see the surfers but
they're way out
so i get maybe i think when we started
getting into football and stuff
it's like the beats started to be less
and less and then
we just never i don't know i never did
are you thinking if i can step in
for a second yeah so like you're gonna
have to get out
like you said it where you want to be is
a little bit further out
you know that's where the good stuff is
it's
best to crush an arm workout like
45 minutes before your first day
yeah well that was interesting too so
like we get in the water
well i have been surfing before though
right right yeah
no but i'm i was like i'm talking to dud
and i'm like
bro i've been on hunts with him like i'm
watching him move through the forest and
he's just like
you know freaking 14 foot legs and he's
just stepping over
like he's stepping over small like yeah
like small trees and stuff like this
and i'm i'm like dude you know and then
watching him shoot i watch him shoot a
ton and then like hawk a football or
whatever i'm like yeah this guy's a
great athlete
and so i'm thinking we're going surfing
and i'm like okay you know he and i said
man you're gonna i was
i told you this i go bro with your long
arms you're gonna just be like oh you
and this big board you're gonna be
you're gonna be like a freaking you know
a cigarette boat just going through the
water
so we go in and i like i said i wasn't
doing any coaching i was just kind of
leaving that josh and i get in the water
and i start paddling out and then i look
back
because dud was going next and then josh
was doing sort of like clean up right
in case something went sideways while we
were getting in
so then i see doug like okay he's good
he's in and then i start paddling and
i'm not like racing but i'm just
paddling out
and then josh comes up next to me and
i'm like oh that's weird i wonder where
dud is so i'm pat a little bit more
and i look back so now it's been like
probably
one minute and 30 seconds maybe i look
back
and as soon as i look back i see dud and
he looks like he's just
like freaking got into a wrestling match
with a bear
like i'm like oh yeah cause here's the
thing
and you brought this up to me a long
time ago uh echo charles
if you're not used to it that's like it
if you're not used to it
it doesn't matter look it matters and if
you weren't in good shape at all then
it would really suck yeah but if you're
not used to that
little particular muscle group and
the technique because you're in the
water and there's balance going on
and yeah it's a little bit yeah
i mean i was laughing at myself because
uh
well first off i didn't know like
where we were going because we were we
were
going to be surfing sets right that were
further out you know i don't
know where it was probably won't say
because i know you have your spots but
so my first experience was we
walked out from the pier and like where
stuff was breaking right there that's
where i was surfing
so when he kind of jumped off the
rock and went out their ways and i was
talking to josh and josh like yeah just
get where you're comfortable and launch
out on your board you know wait
you know wait for a smooth spot and jump
out so
when i did that by that point giaco was
like 100 yards out
so i thought like he's where we where
we're going to be waiting for these
waves
so i just went like full sprint for like
the first 30 seconds
and then josh like as i'm like kind of
starting to burn out
you know that freaking josh just like
strokes by
and they're just going and then jocko's
just looking back he's like
gotta go about 200 more yards and i was
just thinking like
and dude like for bro i was going into
like
i was i was saying this kind of stuff
like bro you got to give me like two
minutes of heart battery
because he was kind of in the lineup
like nothing started he was in the
impact zone
and all of a sudden there's a lull and
i'm like because now i'm rea now i put
everything together in my mind and i'm
thinking if this
if this brother doesn't get out there
like now
he's going to be in here for a long time
so i'm like you got to give me like two
minutes give me like two minutes
of work it was but see i love
like i love that i love something that
you know it's just to me struggle
gives you it like gives you a purpose
you know today when we were waiting to
come here i just sat out there and
watched those things and i was like
thinking about every mistake i made
yesterday and how i would do it
differently
today paddling was one of them uh
but like even yesterday
chalk was like hey dude you know just
hit the garage for your workout so i
went down in there and it's
very different than mine you know so i'm
kind of looking around
looking at the you know the tools trying
to figure out like what i can construct
you know that day so i freaking you know
hit his rings for a while and stuff and
and uh did some kettle bells but then i
also thought like
you know a lot of it's like freaking
gorilla movements
so yeah his wife and girls had some
bands over on the side
so after i you know slung some
kettlebells around for a while
i you know went and grabbed some bands
and just did some like
burnouts of you know shoulders and and
you know freaking arms and stuff
which i thought was a you know i worked
out for an hour i was
pretty happy with you know everything
but
like dude at like
a hundred yards out freaking trying to
paddle that
aircraft carrier and he's like 200 yards
bro and you got it
and i was just like oh my freaking
triceps
you know what he said to me later we got
back he's like he's like yeah you know
bro
i mean i just realized for the first
time that like when you see a surfer
that guy's in like better shape than a
wrestler like he's in sick you got to be
in the sickest shape
because that's how hard it was in a way
but also not a way let's face it you can
be like a
fat old dude that surfs yeah like i'll
take you to
yeah they're just used to it and they
got good technique and they just go out
there and they don't even
you know they don't even freaking try
and they're out it's like when i give a
bodybuilder
you know a bow and watch them like
struggle to get it back
and you're like dude this is a 70 pound
dumbbell row right now yeah
and you can't do it you know and then
because yeah
what is that is that that they don't
have like the the little stabilizer
muscles or something
it's no it's just like it's just the
understanding of like
the technique of like where you're
pushing and pulling
and like the leverage of it it'd be like
you know it'd be just like
walking up and even if a big dude you
said like you know hey do a cleaning
jerk and you just like put 200 pounds on
there you
i mean it's just going to be a training
right they don't have the technique
whereas you get a little female that
knows how to do a cleaning jerk
yeah she'll take that 200 and throw it
up like it's nothing oh we talked about
that on the maze today
yeah about that what the swinging yeah
the big mace yeah
that uh first surfing yeah you're right
like actually
you don't have to be in that good shape
you just have to be used to because it's
so
repetitive like just paddling is so
repetitive it's like not knowing how to
swim
honestly like on that board uh
i just felt like you know the first time
even if someone knows how to swim you
throw them in the water if they don't
know like
stroke and like how to block and breathe
and you're like taking on water in your
mouth and you're like trying to blow
that out and
yeah you know you're freaking sprinting
when there's waves up like and it was
like simple stuff you know i got my
first ride in
i think i was on my like i went up to
one knee yeah one then he got up to one
foot for a little bit
and then like as i'm going back out i'm
just you know taking freaking
taking him on taking the straight line
straight out and i did that a couple
times
and then i'm out there with josh
and jocko had rode one in i'm out there
with josh and a couple
like a big set came that were crashing
kind of further out
and like as we're going up he knew it
was gonna like crash and he goes
he goes bro when you go up he goes do a
push-up on your board right as you're
hitting the
right as you're hitting you know
whatever he called it you know the flake
or
the white water yeah he's like you know
do a push-up on your board and then it
drives the nose down then you can just
ride the back
and i like i freaking went up this thing
and i'm just like
and rode down and i'm just like now you
tell me
dude i freaking was taking like
full endos just freaking one after
another in the in the freaking mortar
zone
just taking heavy artillery jocko and
josh are just out there like watching me
just like
you know he'll be back he'll be back out
here at 15 or whatever
there's a lot of technique man then he
told me the you know
the button hook method the channels yeah
like
the channel we got all the way out and
climbed up on the rocks and
we were there to take a picture of the
three of us
like up at the top of the cliffs and he
goes
see where all those are breaking he's
like yeah that's paddle out
he goes that's he goes that's why i like
i'd write it out this way
and then i'd come in around the back of
that and then josh you know how josh
always wrote out that way and then he'd
come around the back he's like you just
kept going right up the middle
i was like man you think you'd tell me
that like
10 minutes in yeah you know what as you
said
there's like only so many things like
the 97 things that i
wanted to tell you or that josh wanted
to tell you yeah
that just didn't make the chart yet and
then once you once we realized that okay
he's going to be able to survive then
that made it onto the freaking on the
prioritize and execute thing don't just
sit there in the impact zone and try and
paddle out
um hey so i
going back to the business side of
things because again to me
that's one of the that's what makes this
applicable well that's what makes
your story applicable in so many
different realms
is the the business side and the way
you've set things up
you end you ended up eventually kind of
like i don't know if this was your
your your final move no it's not your
final move but your
one of your biggest moves was partnering
up with with pse
yeah i mean that definitely came later
but yeah i mean there
there came a point where our business
had grown
a really awesome community that was
you know thriving for the educational
content and then also
like products that supported that
educational content
which was all you know sharon's side of
the house i was
more you know i come up with things to
talk about
based on someone i'm working with at
that time
but yeah the brand became a community
you know it became you know sharon
always said like
we're not you know we don't have fans we
have
you know we have a community like we
you know we have a knock-on nation that
that's kind of what we referred to it
probably
five years ago you know five or six
years ago which
uh we just turned 10 years old so
you know halfway through we realized you
know like what
really fit our model and then yeah
one of the hard things for me one of the
hardest things
is you know i'm a very loyal person
you know and i've since i've also been
i've worked internally at manufacturers
i look at you know ambassadors
or external representatives in a
different light
than you know if someone's just out
being an ambassador
you know or public figure whatever
whatever you know
it's way different now but when i was
internal and we had
pro staff you know you just
you see what people do that really helps
the company
and makes you like never in question
of should we get you know who are we
going to keep around this year
i just knew those types of things you
know to where
if it was just like with
for me like with my friendships if it's
a two-way street
then you know that's a good relationship
but if it's all
if it's always like you know there's
always a give and a take
then you know that's just not like a
healthy relationship so
from like like you built me a bow you
taught me how to shoot
you took me on haunts and then i broke
your neck that's
that's the good relationship yeah that's
how that's what i'm looking for
that's exactly what i'm looking for
yeah a lot of people don't know that
like when you are here doing the podcast
with andy and trevor
that was day one of jiu jitsu for me
and i was actually in this room i just
couldn't talk because my neck was
broken i was over in that corner just
trying to get
oxygen freaking pull my esophagus
off the back neck bone i had
meanwhile you and nanny are just
freaking laughing man
check all right so so we form these
really good relationships it's a two-way
street just like you and i got
yeah and so it's always been tough when
when you change you know when you if you
change brands because i don't
ever want it to be a reflection of
loyalty but a lot of times
a lot of times like the higher up you go
in what you're giving someone or what
they're giving you
there's obviously there's just more
expectation
and there's more you know i don't know
it's just
like the higher up in rank you go
there's you know
there's things that you need to do
better than other people
and so you know when you climb to that
spot it's sometimes it's hard when you
get to a higher level to then change
because i don't ever want to
people to feel like i'm just making a
change from a monetary point of view
but for me i had gone through
two consecutive contracts that were
multi-year contracts and both of them
kind of got cut
when our business is trajecting you know
in this format but then you know they're
like well
you know we're kind of plateauing from a
marketing point of view and
you know we're not getting added budgets
but we need to make room for other
things so
they were always transparent but it also
became clear of
you know we're trajectoring up and i
want to
i want to provide more free content but
i can't provide free content to the
consumer
if i have no support from you know
by the way when you say your your
trajectory is going up you mean
knock on archery is growing you're
getting more and more people following
there are more people watching your
instructionals on youtube there's just a
whole new archery pie
like you know people people within the
archery community
that pie would be like you know local
surfers around here probably
you know that's probably a pie
whereas if someone just really started
focusing on
you know teaching surfing to people like
me
you know and i came in they like start
this whole other thing to where
these people all over here are probably
looking at like what's this guy even
doing
you know why why is he doing that but
the reality is you know
we're kind of like baking a whole new
cake because the people that we're
getting from the military
and you know the people that we get from
a lot of our mutual friends
like i'm beyond busy just with
our just with people that we know should
be getting into archery
right and uh
at the end of that contract my last one
i
kind of knew i need to open my ears to
everybody
because i had been with that company for
10 straight years
but i also had taken six years of
you know to where things were plateauing
and i could see there wasn't progression
so i listened to everybody and yeah
i mean through everything there was
honestly there was multiple deals that
were better than where i was
but pse came in and pretty much said
like we love what
you're doing and we want you to support
what we're doing but we also want to
give you
the tools to where if you want to do
more we'll give you the tools for that
so they said you know if you feel like
you want to create a bow that's specific
to you know to your followers or if you
want to do something and i said well
you know can i bring in a bow that's
like at a budget price
you know and they just said yeah you
tell us what you wanted to sell for
you know we'll assign an engineer to you
and you can you know you can do
what whatever you want so it was
it was just it was just a different door
you know that got opened that allowed us
to
go a direction with our brand that i
feel good about
and i feel like you know i sleep well
with
just knowing that we're giving back a
lot
and yeah pse has been a huge part of
that
you know they've just given me the tools
you know the first bow we came out with
is the one you and i shoot and then uh
came out with another bow that was
focused on you know
a price to where you the average person
can go and get into archery with a
really good setup
but probably still less than what you
could buy a surfboard for
you know what i mean um and then yeah we
can
choose our direction so it's been an
it's been an awesome partnership
and you know they're an america you know
everything's made in america
um for the stuff that you know we're
designing and
it's just it's really cool because it's
actually the company
my first bow was a pse and last year was
their 50-year
like anniversary so um and pse
started in illinois like very close to
where
that road that i turned down was not
very far from there
so there's just a lot of cool things
like that that you know a lot of times
if things are meant to be they happen
you know i've just
learned that you know if you force stuff
it's not for the right reasons so
i've i've just really i've been
fortunate that i haven't
had to make a decision based on like i
can't pay my bills if i make this
decision
so i've always just let things unfold of
you know really what's meant to be will
be and you know
and i feel like i feel like my
progression of
shooting tournament archery and learning
what i learned there and learning the
connections and
and growing up working with the
manufacturer and seeing some of that
behind the scenes stuff
like all those were just sacrifices and
building blocks that i had to do
to get to where i really want to be you
know i never
i never wanted to be the best tournament
archer i never really wanted to be
you know i didn't want to just work in
an archery
you know manufacturer or you know go to
all the
the shoots i just i love hunting i love
teaching
you know i like i like going to new
spots and seeing new things and having
new challenges so
you know that that's kind of what it's
done for me yeah and
what i like about it and i remember as
this deal was unfolding you were telling
me what it was like and it's like it's a
true partnership like you said you're
allowed to go in there
you can help design exactly what it is
you want
it's your name going on these on this
equipment
so it's like you can't be any more
invested
in this company which is which is
awesome
yes and the other thing too is everyone
needs to remember
you know if you can't shoot it well
there's no purpose to it so
like through that whole process i got
equipment from all these companies that
i really
hadn't done hadn't done a lot of due
diligence
shooting to where i you know because i'd
only
shot two other archery brands really at
from a like professional level
each one for about a decade so um
i shot other competitors to know what
they felt like but that doesn't mean
i knew what they would do like in my
hands every day so i needed to know that
and right away after
three or four days i thought this is a
seriously underrated product you know
and i went out there and and met with
them and they talked about a lot of
things that they wanted to do especially
like at that 50-year
you know they wanted to you know make
some changes
from a sales point of view they wanted
to make some marketing decisions that
were different
you know they said you know we want to
be able to to hit some like niche
markets which
for them our community was a niche
market
which i think was very underrated you
know now
now i think they realize you know what
the impact is
but yeah it really gave the ability for
me to take
people that had incredible ideas
internally
and and awesome patents which you know
for me
would be hard to go out on my own and do
it
because i'd have to work around so many
things that
now that i've shot their bows i
personally like so
you know i would be trying to figure out
a way around
what they've solidified as a you know as
a proven design
so it just it was a for me it was a plug
and play
like and and that's what it it had to be
because you know we've worked really
hard sharon and i
to you know really stay on our path at
knock on archery because there's
there's been a lot of opportunities to
you know maybe
i don't know if sell out would be like
the term
because it probably wouldn't be that
drastic but we could have definitely
made a lot more decisions
that would have put our following
secondary
to decisions that we made and
the pse collaboration was a
was a an awesome plug-and-play for us
and i think as a especially me i feel
like i was an athlete
that built a career out of
the discipline of athletics honestly
um i feel like those are the little
things in business
you know especially now like so many
people build business
based off social media or you know maybe
they've
you know maybe they've been with origin
for you know using your geese for a year
and you guys have been good to them and
you're
you're laying down foundation to get to
where you want origin to go
but then you know brand y comes in and
says
well you know we're not just going to
give you a discount on a ghee we'll give
you a ghee
and you know i was always at the
the mindset of okay
if i get a ghetto at one do i really
need to get a freaky if i've got one
even though i had to buy it from origin
you know
and okay let's say i'd take the free gee
well now i've like also started a brand
new relationship
so you know i think we made a lot of
really good choices
by weighing out like long-term
relationships
that understood the direction we needed
to go but we weren't there yet
but they were going to help at a rate
that they could
to where we could get to our goal versus
like
you know a lot of startups are the
perfect example of like
you know they wait they make a lot of
dumb decisions as i did as a business
you know giving stuff away to the wrong
people and those
those places come and go all the time
and i think as like an embat
you know an ambassador type figure or
whatever
you can i think andy likes to call him
influencers
that's what hashtag influencers yeah
which yeah that's your
official hashtag for andy and i uh
but yeah you could you know you can burn
a lot of bridges
and it's just my experience that a lot
of these
you know jiu jitsu surfing archery
the they're like they're small
demographics they're like small
ecosystems so it's like there's only so
many times you can
burn a hole in the freaking ozone before
eventually
people are like that dude's just burning
the planet down if you know
yeah what i like about you what you guys
what you and sharon have done
and i think this might be the the
biggest lesson that i look at you to try
and pass on other people
is you guys have done the right things
for the right reasons the whole time
you you have put the customer first you
put the clients first you put the people
that are
watching your videos i mean there's
there's
well that's what you've done that's what
you've stuck to making the best products
you can
trying to get them at a good price point
i mean for you to go to psc and like say
okay i could make wonderbo you know and
this super high end bow but you went
there and the first
really i guess the second move you made
because you you did make that first bow
that we're shooting but then you said
okay
here's the first move we're gonna make a
bow that is affordable to people that
still kicks ass
yep so i think one one of the lessons
that i take away from this is like if
you're doing the right things for the
right reasons
in the long run strategically you're
gonna be better off than
you know trying to get trying to
maneuver real quick to make a little bit
a buck here and a buck there like you
said you're burning a hole
in the world that you have to live in
and it ends up not working out well
um i i hate to ask you this because i've
you've probably been asked this 10
000 times but look we've been going for
two and a half hours or something like
that but
if someone is starting if someone's like
hey dude this sounds awesome
i wanna i wanna get into this i wanna
get into archery i wanna get a bow
i wanna you know what i wanna go hunting
i wanna be freaking stalking around in
the forest
with cami paint on my face like i'm in i
want to get into it
what what do you recommend how do you
how do you go about that
well i think first you should just you
know google you know
google archery shops and look at ratings
there's
you know some areas are very fortunate
to have in our
an awesome archery shop that you know
has
amazing you know entry-level
you know classes and programs like that
um but also like especially from our
point of view
knock on archery.com is you know we
offer
free you know lessons and content i just
put out a series you know archery 101
with uh you know mark shanker from
kicks band because you and i both were
like freaking
hair slingers from the 80s no you're
thinking of late babin life babin was a
hair slinger was it not me i wasn't
listening to freaking poison like you
were
i'll give that to you bro hold what you
got
you know you did no offense against
kicks
but they weren't in my freaking tape
deck
what was your top three before we go
black sabbath
motorhead led zeppelin ac dc and then
just straight into all the hardcore
stuff that i grew up on
cromags bad bad brains agnostic front
right on down the line who wants some
well if you wanted that easier listening
you had alternatives
but uh no i we did a we did i just
thought it was a really cool story
because
you know he's he's later in life
decided to pick up jiu jitsu you know
went down that path
you know wanted to honestly wanted to
like get away from factory farming
and so decided to go down the archery
path
and you know wanted to like get good
enough to where he could you know
get his own food so to speak so it was
really cool
and we documented that and that's you
know it was like a three-part series
which takes someone from
who had never pulled the bow back
and just walked walked him through like
you know
same thing i did with helen right you
know and learning
i didn't know anything about archery you
look in man
so thankful that you decided like hey
you will
you are going to really like this stuff
because you heard me on rogan and you're
like
this guy needs to get a freaking bow so
you set it up you came out here
freaking uh like what do they say like
it's not gonna come to you on a silver
platter right in life things are gonna
come to you on a silver platter
i literally got archery on a silver
platter and i know it
to everyone out there that's like this
zombo [ __ ] just had
freaking dudley build my bow and then
teach me like that's what happened i
know
i'm sorry that i got that freaking lucky
you know my buddy jack daniels at
echelon front you know jack
bro he he's like man yeah he's like
he's like man dudley taught you how to
shoot man he's like so
freaking pumped um so i know that
i know that i got that but one but i i
didn't even watch any of your videos
like before you came out to teach me and
so then immediately i go home and i'm
like all right what are these videos
that he's talking about
and i'm like oh that's literally just
what he told me to do
yeah like i went through and i'm like oh
this is what you
so anybody that's thinking i got so
lucky i did i'm not taking that away
but you can get just as lucky by going
and pressing freaking play on a youtube
video and you're gonna get
you said the exact same things to me
you're like hey this is what you need to
do here's where you start here's the
string here's this
and i'm like okay cool and i'm doing it
and i go home and watch the videos i'm
like that's what he just told me he
could have just sent me the youtube
link he didn't have to fly out here to
san diego so
every you the fact that you've given
access to
your actual program of coaching
and it's available to anybody yep it's
available to anybody
so and on our youtube channel you and i
parallel
each other in that format like
um and i heard you talk about it in the
past you've talked about
you know like you know for extreme
ownership right when you first started
doing it and you would
you know probably when you started you
would get cash by going in places and
doing that presentation
which is kind of like when i used to
travel europe
and like my slide shows you know if
people
took pictures of them it kind of weirded
me out like
i need to be booking you know i need to
book another spot
that's how i'm paying for my bills you
know but then it gets to the point where
you realize
no actually the more people you're
helping
the more people that want to dive deeper
so you know there came a point for me
where i kind of knew i was going down
the right road
when people that were on higher levels
were getting mad at me because
they're like don't show them how to do
that you know
why are you showing them how to do that
dude you know and
because the u.s was so dominant in
archery competition
for a long time in the compound bow
category and so like learning that
ranging system on the unknown things
like you know that was
never tell anyone that sort of thing um
but just all these small little things
you know we'd go to another country and
see him like
punching triggers or something and you
know my buddy look at me like you
freaking talk to them about punching
that trigger and i'm gonna punch you in
the face
let's freaking nuke these people
so but yeah i just felt like um
the more i the more i gave away it's
also a really good filter because
you really start to see how many people
are absorbing what you're saying
and not you know not being an [ __ ]
where they're just asking and they never
apply
ask never reply never reply you see
people where you look at them and you're
like oh hey man
when did you start shooting that silver
back and they're like yeah i watched you
know video blah blah blah and i've been
working on it i think i'm getting better
and meanwhile i know this because i'm
seeing
you know what i try to teach being
applied by someone that
i know i didn't directly tell it to so
then naturally it's like
well hey let me give you a little bit
you know let me
help you progress progress this a little
bit and i feel like
um for you and i both you know we just
got to the point where we
where we realized lay it all out there
and yeah there's there's certain places
that
will say dudley will give you anything
to to come out here and like do it in
person and blah blah blah
and yeah i've got people um you know
we've auctioned
a couple bows that have gone you know
for a lot for good
always for a good cause but we we
auctioned a ball
a bow that went for a lot uh for the
navy seal foundation to get to that
million dollar
march to a million mark and uh
you know even though it was a raffle you
know people still well
you know not everyone's got 20 bucks to
buy a bunch of raffle tickets and it's
like
you know you can't make everyone happy
but the reality is
you know if someone really wants to go
through and put it all together
they can you know they can read all
these
and you know so many different things
that i've heard you
talk to people you know and and
give them i don't know you
people will come and be like hey you
know jocko give me some advice about
this
and then you know go through and look in
here and i'm like oh yeah well
you know i've heard him apply that exact
same thing and they acted like
you know he just told them something
that's never been said and it's like
actually
if they if yeah if they would follow
that like you know
i'm a broken record when it comes to
archery i've
i've boiled down a recipe to you know
what i feel is
like a balsamic glaze it's like the good
stuff
you know and i know like what can make
most
archers who are brand new be at a very
high level fast
and eliminate a lot of mistakes but
you know whether you watch every video i
have
or read all those articles or you come
in person
now granted it's easier for me to see in
person
a breakdown which that is the benefit to
being in person
you can directly connect like right away
you're not having to figure out what am
i doing wrong and research it
but other than that like we put it all
out there if i learn something new
or if we come out with a new product
then you know we're we're going to put
it out there and
most of everything we do is always
it's always a derid a derivative of
a need that i see that we can help
with um and i remember specifically like
on that bow that we were talking about
uh i have chalkboards all around me like
you've been to my house and stuff
most anywhere where i if i
sit down and i'm in there very long
there's
chalk you know most of my walls are just
painted with chalkboard paint
because i just write stuff down so i
don't forget it but
i remember like meeting this person that
kind of said like
hey you know i'd love to embark on an
archery journey where do i start
and so i remember like writing that down
which is the name of that bow
is embark because i'm like you know
embark on your first archery journey
embark on your first bow hunt
you know um so a lot of
the things that we put out there are
because there was a need
you know my subject matter comes from
someone's problem that i need to help
them fix yeah and i've been the subject
of that
a few times on your social media you're
like hey let's start looking at jocko's
shot
he's doing this and i'm like there you
go and it's awesome
you know and and that's the way it
should be you know what's funny is
what's not funny but
probably like the third podcast that we
were doing or maybe the fourth something
but very early on in the podcast i
remember i had been asked a question
about leadership and i was going to give
the answer and i was like
this answer that i'm about to give is
like very very very valuable and
it didn't it wasn't like i had a major
debate in my mind but it was more just
an acceptance
it wasn't like i said maybe i shouldn't
give it away but it was more like i said
when i give this away this is giving
away something very very valuable
and i and that's what i'm gonna do like
maybe there's a little bit like well you
know cause i
look i have a leadership consulting
company yeah right
that's what i do is i do leadership
consulting if i'm just get you know
hey go ahead i'm just going to give away
all the answers for free
well maybe that's not a good idea and i
don't if i had that thought it was like
a split second and i realized i was like
no
actually every possible thing that i can
give to people to help them that's what
we're doing that's what i'm doing
and and that's what you do and like you
said what helps is
that solves look no one in life is going
to get to the end of their problems
right no one's going to get to a point
where they're just like oh i don't have
any problems anymore with leadership
right oh i've got everything figured out
no one
and so there's so you solve
a bunch of their problems cool then
guess what now when you work with them
you can do
a problem that's actually a little bit
more complex yeah it's actually a little
bit more challenging
you know like i get kind of like you you
get asked
hey dud you know i'm uh you know
sometimes i hit a little bit low to the
left
and they're thinking that that's the
first time you've ever been asked that
you know what i mean or they say
hey you know i once i'm sitting on our
target i start my
i start to my hand starts to shake a
little bit like they're thinking that
this is only happening to them
you've been asked that question 15
million times right
it happens to me too like you know hey
jocko i know you talk about cover move
but sometimes the people i'm working
with they don't really
you know they don't want to do their
part so how does that even work it's
like i've been they think that that's
the only time that's ever happened and
it's actually happened 15 million times
that i've been asked that question
so give it away give away as much as you
can
to people and that elevates everybody
and that means they're
they're seeing value in what you're
doing and they're appreciative and now
guess what
they get their problems prob that
problem solved cool
if they never have a problem again
that's great cool that's great
good for them that's awesome i'm happy
someone else is going to have that
problem i'm going to learn by the way
it's just it's just it's doing the right
things for the right reasons like i said
earlier if you're doing the right things
for the right reasons it's going to pay
off in the end
you and i are really similar in a lot of
ways like you know right now
sharon and i are staying you know in
your old house
um so just lurking around and
you know seeing some of your stuff i
mean you're
you're not like a gadgety person you're
very like even your weights
are you know the first one you got at
ebay or where you know
before ebay when you walked in the
freaking second wind fitness or whatever
freaking bought this rusty old freaking
thing you got
uh but you
don't get freaking old school you do
what
you do everything you do is that way but
i'm glad you knew that the bands you
used to work out were not mine
they were my wifes and daughters
but i think uh your consistency with
like
you get good at the tools you have
and you you build yourself around those
tools
you don't get tools to try to continue
to make you better
you know you're not like looking for the
cheat code looking for the cheat code
yeah i know you talk about that looking
for a hack like oh this if i get this
it'll make me a little bit it'll make it
a little bit easier
now i'm glad we're not talking about
surfboards because you also saw my
amount of surfboards that i have which
is kind of freaking ridiculous yeah
yeah surfboards is it's like a freaking
junkyard of surfboards all over the
place yeah and there's a little bit of
an
excuse for that because different waves
require different boards
yeah there's a lot of different ways to
surf i mean my archery room looks very
similar to that but i don't change
unless there's a change needed for the
application
now one of the things with me is i never
really had
great continual coaching a lot of the
things that i teach
are from mistakes like no one ever told
me why i missed low left
i had to figure that out over a lot of
frustration
and so like once i've learned those
things
everything i boil down is to try to help
eliminate those mistakes
and learning curves you know shouldn't
say it's cheat codes but
just like me i'm freaking surfing
yesterday
i do try to take a direct line of attack
so my coaching method is very direct
line of attack to where
you're eliminating mistakes but like
getting to
that particular point of topic as
efficient as possible to where you're
not
expending valuable energy in that
archery shot
i just want to make sure we capture a
couple things here
so i'm never done archery before and i
want to get into archery
what's we we look for a good archery
shop we read the reviews
we what's a good amount of money to
spend on that first investment
is it better to go and like hey should
you go and try like hey can i try a bow
like let me shoot some and see what it
feels like in the shop
just to just to make sure you're like oh
yeah this is freaking cool
or is it like you know spend a thousand
bucks spend
800 bucks what's gonna get you in the
game
well i think if you go there and you you
try it most archery shops are going to
let you
try it a little bit i think that would
be valuable
and be really specific to them to where
you're new you want to make sure you buy
equipment that's
very suited for you as a beginner um
and one of the examples of that is when
you buy a bow they have like
you know they all have pulling weight so
when you pull them back
you know it takes a certain amount of
strength to pull them back i'm real
strong
yeah i want 500 pounds yeah that's
jocko walking in uh but a beginner
like our wives for example if they went
into a lot of shops
some shops especially if they were
excited and just wanted to buy it right
then
they would make do with equipment that
they have and like
size it down for them versus i would way
rather say
hey i'll wait a couple weeks to order
something to work you know
it's my pull weight the bow is the right
size for me
because they can always make it work but
you know getting the right equipment off
the get-go
and being upfront with them of hey i
really want to do this i enjoy it
i want the right equipment and it's my
personal belief that
if you get in on like the lower end
stuff
you're gonna you can progress really
fast with archery
so what will happen is you're going to
do it just a short period of time and
realize
i'm actually better than this beginner
piece of equipment and then you realize
the value of beginner equipment
is kind of a poor investment because
it's just
you're going to sell it for way less
because everybody
got that cheap entry point
um so like with the bow that we did the
embark
that bow allows you to get a bow at a
price
to where you can put some really
high-end accessories on it because the
accessories can carry over
it'd be like you know if you went and
got
a you know a cool freaking ar
but then like you sh you know shot your
wad on buying that thing
so then you went you know you went and
bought a new ski
and then you're like well i got 50 bucks
left and you got to borrow your buddies
like red rider
bb gun like scope that came on it to
like put on your noveski
that's gonna be a problem so i tell
people you know get high-end accessories
get you know quality arrows high-end
accessories
get a bow that's in the middle of the
road to where if you
move up in that bow you can transfer
your accessories over
which you know we we've done with you
you know we can transfer the accessory i
went
high end on your accessories because you
don't want accessory like you don't want
your site moving
you know if you're if your site's moving
around or if your arrow rest is moving
around then
there's none of us that are going to
know how well you're really shooting
because
there's just continual variables but i
think
i think for a thousand bucks you can
get in to where you can get in and stay
in without having to re-up and re-up and
re-up
um but you want something that has the
ability to
especially if you're still growing you
want to have a cam system
that and that's kind of the pulley
looking things on the bow
you want to be able to have something
that's adjustable and especially when
you're learning
like as a coach i'm not going to be
hypersensitive of you
being exactly your draw length which is
like
your posture when you're at
like a full draw position with your bow
pulling it back because you can pull a
bow back to different
lengths there's a good chance that your
technique is going to slightly change
over the course of getting better to
where you might need to make some
adjustments with that so having
something that has the ability to adjust
is also awesome which you get when you
spend it's kind of like i think there's
like 100
increments like you can get a bow for
400 bucks but you're gonna be limited
you know and then i think once you get
to like
6.99 7.99 for the bow only you're in a
really good position
and then put good accessories on it and
you know you'll be enjoying it
for a while that that level bow
like the embark like you you go out and
hunt with that thing
this is yeah i'll i'll shoot one day
at the tax we'll be with an embark and
then one day i'll be
with an ntn like when i you know i and
last year um i took that bow
you know on one of my most memorable
hunts you know because i've always
that's one thing i've always done is i
want people to feel like
even though for a particular brand
they have a low end model a mid-grade
model and a high-end model
i've always put some of those budget
bows
to a test and i've used them because i
want i don't want people to feel like
they can only
shoot archery if they have the best gear
i've proven time and time and time again
that that middle range is a is a very
good place to get in
and you can honestly you can stay there
and be totally okay but you know it's no
different than
you know there's a lot of cars that are
awesome but
you know i like my ram but
i might want that hellcat ram
even though technically it drives the
same
yeah right on well i think that's uh
that's good info and i'm sure a bunch of
people
it's probably good yeah we're
approaching three hours right now but
i just wanted to make sure people are
going to get interested in this i want
people to and by the way you have
all this information on on your youtube
channel about like
how to get started what to look for
everything from freaking arrows to the
like everything so yeah it's it's all
out there if you want to go a little bit
deeper
um but yeah man i obviously
i appreciate you coming on but man i
appreciate
i appreciate what you're doing what
you're doing for
veterans you know that are out there
what you're doing for your whole
community of people that are making
their life better because they're out
there
they got they got a mission and and
absolutely what you've done for me
helped me out delivering silver platter
bow hunting to me which again i'm sorry
for everyone for being so spoiled
uh i'm lucky and i appreciate it but man
it's been awesome and
and i want to help get other people
heading down that path because
man i think it's beneficial in so many
different ways man yeah it is
100 i think it's an awesome and awesome
sport especially for people that come
from your background
um who are looking for a new mission you
know you said it perfectly because
with all of you guys who have done it
you know learning a new discipline or a
new trade
is one thing but then once it comes to
like packing up to freaking go on call
that lights a whole different intensity
where you know hey we're meeting you
know
we're we're we're out at dark back at
dark
and when you're out there you know
geared up and freaking ready to get
after it
you know i remember the first time you
and i went out
and we were on that hillside glassing
and you just said bro this freaking
this is recon right now like you know
i'd have a team right over there
there'd be freaking two dudes right
there they'd be like you know
back up and then we'd be here and like
you know the [ __ ] would be all pulled
over tight
you know it was you were in your element
just dorking out
yeah well you were head freaking dork on
the scenario so
it's all good awesome man echo
charles you can see what kind of
focus and consistency it takes to uh
to approach excellence in any element
cognitive focus but the pursuit never
stops the pursuit of excellence doesn't
stop
what suggestions do you have
you know we talked about uh being an
athlete
right the importance the value of being
an athlete which i was
was with you the whole time i agree
fully but we don't want to stop that
just because we get older
and take on other responsibilities are
you getting older well that's gotta suck
it's just one of those things man the
life i live nonetheless
we gotta stay in the game even on our
off time
there's no off time on time this is just
time something like that nonetheless
we have things to help you through this
journey supplementation first thing you
talk about focus we have discipline
discipline i'm glad i was able to look
at you just to get you on track bro
cause you were starting to stray
whatever you i could probably chime in
on a few things because i can tell you
like three things that are pinnacles for
me
from you know from origin
cold war freaking joint warfare and the
vitamin d
and freaking have powered through
coved you know coven year was like no
factor
no factor but i was those those three
for me
are every day that are like right next
to my cup of coffee where i know i'm
getting after it first thing in the
morning
yeah that's um those are those are
freaking legit the joint warfare
is the go read
the reviews on joint warfare don't
listen to me who am i i'm free i own the
company of course i'm gonna tell you
it's good right
go read the reviews from other people
and what it does to them and what they
say that grandmother started taking it
now all of a sudden you know she's
whatever playing tennis again and
whatnot
you know yeah it's true but this is
the whole purpose yeah you own the
company cool but the whole purpose
that you have this stuff is because that
was like your pursuit even before that
true like yeah you got to take the stuff
krill oil uh
you know all the ingredients you know
that well you added some ingredients and
then
where you stack that up to make this
better because why not like it's not
like oh i'm just going to take no
make it better make it the best possible
thing that you can put
into your mouth to make your freaking
joints bulletproof
son yeah yeah true and i'm with you with
that that combo every day
um the cold war not as much that that's
kind of a seasonal
thing don't like the cold super krill 2.
get that krill oil on man
get them little fish down what are they
fish no little shrimp
little shrimps little tiny shrimps kind
of like shrimps yeah
fish well good too though you know i
might want to look at you fish oil is
good
yeah you're right chocolate is a label
he's read it and researched it there's a
reason that we
see fish oil is like whatever that's
your freaking
four hundred dollar bow yeah krill
that's the entry or the krill oil is the
freaking top of the line
is the top of the line super krill is
where it's at
i understand fully um i mentioned the
discipline discipline go
look hey look some of us are into energy
drinks
but really we're not into energy drinks
we're into the idea of energy drinks and
what they don't tell you about the whole
energy drink thing is that there's
poison inside straight up normal
energy drinks yeah tradition
that's why yeah so this is the upgrade
this is the i don't know whatever you
guys call it so you know i don't think
it's an upgrade i think it's new
category
yeah it's new category it's like oh
we're over here drinking poison you're
over here drinking something that's
awesome for you
clean alternatives is like a long
overdue category for because think of
how many guys
went in and got after it in victory
and then walked out and just grabbed
dog crap in a plastic bottle to like
have
something on the way out the door it is
way past you yeah way past you yeah it's
almost like
and i'm not as in touch with it but i'm
you know i'm a casual we'll say but it
seems like the whole energy
casual or what it's i mean besides life
everything what else all of the above
you said you're a casual what are you
talking about
energy drinks oh before you see if it
wasn't for me being on deployment
like like with with energy drinks
and needing them because i need it's
like hey i'm freaking wicked tired
and i've been awake for 48 hours and i
need caffeine into my system
that's why i started drinking energy
drinks and then
but what do you deal with you deal with
oh i got done drinking the energy drink
now i i don't have that way
freaking out anymore and now i feel like
dog
[ __ ] yeah yeah and that's exactly
because there's a bunch of
junk in there that's exactly what i'm
saying and you're talking about like
extra what about when you're in the club
what about you when you were freaking
doorman of the year or whatever
i never i never
i never got into energy drinks as much
you know every once in a while or
whatever
i just drink coffee because they have
coffee available whatever
as far as staying up no but i'm talking
about like activity you're talking about
going on deployment
all this i don't like the taste of
coffee okay yeah i understand sir i was
talking to evan
and evan's like bro he's like he's like
i want to get bring up to utah and i you
know i'm gonna figure out what
what um coffee you know what coffee you
like this you know there's got to be a
way you know he's like a
he's like a sommelier of the java bean
right and he's like wanting to create it
he was texting me this he's like yeah
the bean that you like and the roast
that you like and all the stuff i texted
him back i go
bro i don't even like coffee ice cream
good luck
and he started laughing but that's kind
of an important factor right there
because
coffee like coffee is like beer where
it's like at the end of the day you're
always going to have the beer
flavor there's a beer flavor it's like
there's a coffee flavor and then from
that flavor there
if it was all the different bridals
tasting like coffee it wouldn't be
coffee
exactly if you made it with freaking
cocoa beans it wouldn't be coffee
yes right if you made it with tea leaves
it wouldn't be coffee correct yeah
exactly right
or strawberries or whatever evan was
trying to put on your
flavor we'll see i don't know he's a
freaking he's into it man
he maybe he can pull it off we'll see
it's chocolate peanut butter you might
be all over that
well that's like you with milk bro like
i sent you like a whatever you got some
milk and then like
two weeks later like okay you're like a
freaking cracker
yeah it's true but the energy drinks is
like a lot of these activities that
they're
sometimes in my observation which is
limited i know but
in my observation it's associated with
these activities
that are kind of let's just say they
would benefit more from a healthy
oh for sure fuel for source yeah why
would you be doing out something that's
physically demanding and putting poison
in your body
so you okay don't do it you go to big
sky whatever you know that hill you're
always
sending me videos of you guys charging
or whatever what's it called the pig
what's a mountain yeah
yeah oh of course what is that called
just tell me if you say
yeah bro when i ran up that thing after
you and i were like kept walking down
that mountain every day and be like man
this would be a good workout
when i went and did i was like yup
confirmed that sucks
yeah and that's what i'm saying so so i
need you right the lift up there okay so
in the snow we'll say if you're really
used to it okay good
but just being in the snow just like
just being in the ocean
or on deployment or in the in the woods
pardon my lack of terminology but um it
is technically it is woods
okay just being there bro it's like
that's in and of itself is a thing
like you can't you're not just cruising
you're just you're working right okay
and then you're doing your activity on
top of that and whether you're in big
sky
you know the woods the water whatever
like right you're gonna
you're not gonna want poison in that
scenario right there no
or even anything that you're gonna pay
the price later or something like that
and it's not needed you don't need to
no you don't need to have poison and
that's why you guys the blink of the
good stuff
in the house hey wawa if you want this
stuff here on the east coast go to wawa
and you know they were saying they tried
to pull the reins on us they're like
don't
don't tell everyone to clear the shelf
stop stop saying we're customers
we're back see if you can run that
supply chain into the ground i challenge
you all to see if you can run that
supply chain into the ground for me see
what happens
if you do i'll figure something out i'll
do what's something i could do
like make a funny hat put on a funny hat
and do a
video or something grow those bangs back
a haircut back that ain't happening
to me it's bothersome to me when my hair
is like a quarter of an inch long or
whatever like it already bothers me so
go
going that distance would freaking drive
me crazy unacceptable yeah
uh vitamin c or something else oh yeah
vitamin chop and there's a subscription
scenario
you don't want to run out of that uh
that that everyday
um supply you know jockoful.com which by
the way is where you need
to think they called the good good
what's the good good
well here's the deal man we're we're not
look we're not alone in the world
good good there's there's capitalism out
here we're competing on an open market
we're competing with some people that
are pretty big
so when you compete with people that are
pretty big you got to figure out how
you're going to make something happen so
what we wanted to do is free shipping
right because people are very used to
free shipping
because there's some companies out there
that do free shipping and so
how do we how can we make that happen
the way we made it happen is if you
get subscriptions to any of these
products the boom shipping's free there
you go
all right cool uh also originusa.com
okay this is where you can get
american-made
stuff from jiu-jitsu stuff all the way
down to non-jiu-jitsu everyday stuff
like for real everyday stuff like jeans
like jeans
like wallets boots yeah still waiting on
my hat pete
which hat a beanie a a ball cap
no you know the one that he wears
what are they called flat cap those are
called a flat cap but they're like
kind of the frenchy ones yeah it's like
it's called a flat cap it's not like a
fedora
no it's a it's called a flat cap it's
like what you see like a
little british dude wear it dude andy
got me one in france
a camo one that i wear sometimes and
it's made out of ammo flat cap
yeah dude legit and it's made out of
like
sweatshirt material and it's freaking
comfy on your head
i hunted with it i told pete like make
me that out of my
origin hoodie material because that
hoodie is like
the my favorite thing i wear around the
house every day
oh yeah that thing's freaking the
freaking mid weight that soft
ass one that's freaking awesome right
you used to say
the most comfortable sweat suit ever in
existence they make pants to match that
yeah they do
that are like longer than 28 inches
or oh yeah you gotta you got a situation
we'll sew two pairs together
for your freaking long ass legs
i heard that where i saw they had some
socks brewing yep
socks are brewing we're gonna make
everything interesting make everything
everything
we're bringing it back to america we're
gonna make it so you can wear it
and we will make like they're making all
these different like cool socks but at
some point i'm just gonna make straight
up
white socks like you know i roll hey you
have a lot of good ideas
you do that one when are you gonna make
a jock strap
dude you need to make a jock strap
that's a good call man that's a great
that's a that's a great one
i've been hearing that joke since i was
in third grade
well for good reason
uh but yeah good yes all american-made
stuff
really good also jacques store it's
called jocko store and this is where you
can get
shirts and rash guards and hoodies and
hats and stuff
that are representative of the path
directly
and then there's the shirt locker which
this is how this is what
savage yeah by the way this is what this
is how savage people are
so we have this thing called the shirt
locker yeah it's it's a subscription
and if you're on the subscription you
get like a one-off t-shirt
yeah like if you have to be on like you
can't go buy it later
so somebody's actually i think a couple
people are already
jacking the designs i don't even know
how they're doing that that this it's
not like
that design is like on display people
posted it
people posted the real one so like and
then then they jack it and they put it
on these websites like hey
it's freaking ridiculous that's how
savage people
it is savage and it is lame but it's
there's like a few
you told me i only use the word savage
in a negative way but i all no i
definitely use it in a positive way
yeah more often i think you just you
just more attuned to it
because i say it with such disc like
those just that's just
what a savage yeah when when somebody's
like doesn't have the creativity to
figure out how to make a cool t-shirt
and sell it instead
they're just savages and just stealing
the design
yeah what who does that yeah it yeah
it's it's
savages now what's jacked up is you
could also be like oh man
like you can it can obviously be super
positive thing
like all these dudes like you said
earlier you're like hey where the guida
twins are from or where the guider
brothers are from there's a bunch of
savages in their neighborhood they're
wrestlers and their fighters and i was
like yeah cool i totally knew what you
were talking about yeah
so it's one of those words that can go
either way but that's a compliment word
we've had many conversations where if
jocko says savage
it's it's a high compliment for someone
that doesn't know they just got one
it is a weird thing because i use it as
the highest co
one of the highest compliments one of
the lowest insults i can give it's
literally the same word
that dude's a savage or that dude's a
savage
what a freaking bunch of savages
i don't know how they get the the design
because it's not like okay like the one
okay so
hardcore condos are good or this one
equals freedom you go to like
i don't want to tell anyone how to get
it but it's on display somewhere you
know
but the shirt locker ones they tend
they're not there's like a hint of them
somewhere
no but no no people are taking when they
get their shirt locker shirt oh
and they're posting it like yo got the
new shirt locker shirt
oh yeah and they gave it over okay so
how they how they do that right the
knockoffs basically the counterfeit
pirated like designed shirts they go to
one of these
like internet yeah yeah yeah uh what do
you call
purchase by to order the recipe or
whatever
no you can do it here's the here's how
bad it is if you if you know about it
and you can if you just have like half a
brain no offense to the people who
bought those
but you can tell you look at it and it's
like this weird like
mock-up of the design on this real like
real like what do you call it model it's
like when you buy a metallica t-shirt
like from some dude on the beach
yeah and it looks like there's like
plastic stickers
yeah yeah exactly stuck to your freaking
shirt oh yeah well what i feel bad about
is though
is i know that some people are doing
like they're like oh cool like i want to
support because we're like you like hey
man
if you want to support what's going on
here then you get some get some gear
and so they actually are stoked like oh
cool i'm helping out you know the
podcast we're in the game
and then they realize they're giving
their money to some freaking
freaking savage out there then stop the
savage support
yeah yeah and they yeah and they use
like super when i say substandard
material it's like
you know it's like the internet shirt
that you print
yeah you know it's like that then they
get that
not to mention there's more to it than
just that front design there's a lot
more to it oh there's
like layers there's little there's
little elements of the shirt if you
examine it you're like okay
i'm in the game with this shirt even on
a physical level
not to mention the philosophical level
and you don't get that either man so
it's brutal
anyway if you want the uh if you want to
get involved with the shirt locker or
any of these other things jackostore.com
also we got uh you know you should
possibly subscribe to this podcast but
but on top of that so you have a podcast
there's there's a there's a uh
podcast it's knock on podcast and
it's talking about archery but it's not
just talking about archery you talk
about you interview
you know dudes yeah cool people
different people from different
walks of life how they got where they're
that where they are
of course you do cover if you just want
to get freaking
granular on some archery [ __ ] well you
can go
you'll get so granular you won't even
know where you are anymore
yeah we've imploded friends that try to
go
too deep down the archery rat hole like
we had one
blow up today it's just freaking good
too
you got to be careful man it's like
crack dude you know like
you got to be careful you start going
down that rabbit hole next thing you
know you look up and your world's
exploded
uh so yeah check out check out that
podcast knock on podcast we want to hear
more about
archery and just other aspects of life
obviously you can subscribe to this
podcast
um we also have jocko unraveling i've
been rolling out some some episodes with
with with uh daryl cooper which are
which are kind of some crazy episodes
coming out and they're just getting
crazier
him we want to talk about me and him are
like rabbit hole freaking
uh uh point man vietnam going deep
into some mayhem with a with an angle
flashlight and a 45 caliber pistol and
we're going down some holes that they're
scary
so you can come check that out we've got
the grounded podcast we get the warrior
kid podcast
uh we can also you can also join us on
the underground for the jocko
underground
which is it's just a little
it's a little like when you like here's
here's something you'll understand echo
charles you used to work in the clubs
right yeah you're in the clubs yeah
you're in the clubs
i wouldn't say and there's like the
front door right where people are coming
in
right and they're feeling like yeah i'm
in the club yeah but then there's also
like a vip
scenario okay there's something else
going on right he calls it the back door
yeah
so there's something else there's like a
little bit more right going on yeah
so we have we have the jaco underground
podcast jockowinderground.com if you
want to if you want to come and hang out
a little bit more
echo and i are we're in there we're
chilling we got bottle service back
there i guess
is that the type of thing that's going
on yeah there
sure there's bottle service going on
there's bottle services metaphorically
metaphorically because you can send a
question and and
if you're in the underground you can
send a question we're going through
those questions
we're i'm putting out little um other
things that i'm diving into
yeah and they're interesting because
they explain a lot like when you listen
to it you're like and you kind of put it
all together if you're one of those
people who are like oh i see what he did
there when you remember some stuff that
you heard you're like oh and it starts
to paint this bigger picture and explain
a lot of the stuff
yeah there's a there's a holistic
viewpoint that starts to come into the
horizon
so go to jockowunderground.com if you
want to get in there costs 8.18
a month we're trying to jack all your
money
no if you can't afford it go go to
assistance at jockowunderground.com
but we do need to have a contingency in
case things go sideways
in case freaking big brother comes down
and just starts
stomping out freedom of speech we gotta
have a little
access port to be able to still do what
we're doing and put out the word
we also don't want to have a bunch of uh
of uh
sponsors that are saying
um hey we don't want you to talk about
this because we think it might be
offensive to our brand we're not doing
that
jockowunderground.com uh youtube we got
a youtube channel where echo puts up
videos
also all kinds of
more information than you could shake a
stick at
knock on archery so check those out
for a bunch of information also origin
usa
has a little youtube channel talking
about what's going on up in
farmington maine we got psychological
warfare what's that all about echo
channel it's an
album it's a jocko album with jocko
tracks on it helping
us get through our moments of weakness
if they may come about
100 effective by the way excellent
we got some books final spin
it's a novel it's kind of a novel it's
it's kind of crazy it's cool
the final edits are coming back right
now um and you always get like little
comments
and we'll just say it's going to be
interesting to see how this one hits oh
comments with the edits
yeah yeah they'll put like something
they'll give you edits but then they'll
be like you know right
it's like yeah so we're getting it's
check it out
if you want that first to dish
leadership strategy and tactics field
manual the code the evaluation is the
protocol this clinical freedom field
manual
way the warrior kid one two three and
four mikey and the dragons
about face by colonel david hackworth
you're going through that right now
right yep
three quarters of the way through i
guess you're listening to it
yeah how's that i listened to some of it
it seems like the guy is a pretty good
reader
yeah yeah i agree i mean some of these
readers are just defensive like you
listen to them and you're like this guy
is just picked us up for the first time
he has no idea what's going on no
contacts and he's just reading the words
on the page
i thought that the first like hour i
probably thought
but then some of the things that he
wrote reminded me of my grandfather so
much
to where now when i hear it i hear my
grandpa
talking because he was he was
gritty you know korean war gritty
and depression gritty so like i'm
hearing him
tell it how it is and you know
and even like the terminology like he
was a good man
that was classic you know that was
classic papa right there he's like he
you know
he was a good man or you know that that
that man's a
coward or you know he was like
there was a clear line you're above it
or below it that was it
yeah yeah hackworth hackworth definitely
does that
uh hackworth said this guy the guys are
either studs
or duds no offense
totally true uh
we got echelon from leadership
consultancy we solve problems through
leadership you go to ashlandfront.com
for details there we have ef online
which is which is online training for
leadership
we have musters where we get together
and we get granular
on leadership we're executing these this
year the only reason we didn't
we were going to execute one last year
the last one of the year
and then i got miss rona so we had to
freaking cancel that thing
um but we're doing orlando may 25th and
26 phoenix
august 17th and 18th las vegas october
28th and 29th
go to extremeownership.com we've sold
out every event that we've ever done
so and these events are we have less
seats because of social distancing and
whatnot
so there's less seats so if you want to
come get there
asap we have ef battlefield where we
go out onto actual battlefields the next
one's coming up are in
we're doing the battle of gettysburg we
sold out the first one we opened up a
second one
register asap if you want to come to
that and if you want to help
service members active and retired you
want to help their families you want to
help gold star families you can check
out
mark lee's mom markley's mom has her own
charity organization and if you want to
donate or you want to get involved
go to americasmightywarriors.org and if
you want more of my
sustained sagas or you want
more of echo's mysterious meanderings
you can find us on the interwebs on
twitter instagram and on facebook
echoes that echo charles i am at jogger
willing dudley
so dudley can be found at
knockonarchery.com
and then on instagram facebook and
twitter it's at
knock on tv yep what else
sounds youtube knock on archery yep yeah
justin says knock on tv
oh okay check wait wait twitter might be
twitter is too i checked him this
morning and and facebook looks like that
too
echo you got anything else uh yeah if
like
i have kids that i want them to get in
art into archery obviously you have
you know direction for that scenario oh
yeah yep
no same exact thing doesn't matter the
age group you know look for a good shop
see if they have a good youth program if
not then
dive down the down the youtube rat hole
or you know follow on social media try
to give
some type of free education you know
if not every day every other day i mean
a lot of what i do is just
trying to help the archery lifestyle in
some for former fashion
is there so i got my son he's four a
ball from amazon he it's and it's like
perfect where he puts a lot of effort
and then he can pull it back so i
remember pulling
is it like a compound bow no it's like
four
yeah it's the kind where i pulled the
back i was like oh he might not be able
to do this and then but when he does it
he can do it
mm-hmm but what's it shooting suction
cups or what's it shooting like
nerf things or what's it shooting i
would say
i don't yeah i don't know about all the
arrow tips
heads what is it what is the end of it
it looks
it reminds me of looks like you know the
old school like you know if you have
archery class at school
you know the thing like it's it's it's
not sharp but it's made to stick into
something
a blunt point yeah like but it has a
little tip to it kind of
kind of a thing but you couldn't like
cut yourself just by scrapping
scratching yourself with that but
the question is like if i just buy a
random bow like that is that
like a note like should i not do that or
honestly with kids that are that young
just let them freaking watch arrows fly
and have fun
okay that was my mindset pull back and
let it rip keep them close
so you know i tell people you know kids
like playing
games that they always win at so you
know if you
try to make your kid shoot it a target
at your distance
it's going to be problematic you know
keep it keep a target big
keep them close if they see themselves
hitting in the middle they don't really
make the correlation of
well that target's bigger than dads or
this one's closer they're you know if
you're just like all right
you know you shoot for the gold i'm
gonna shoot for the gold let's you know
and if they're like i beat you again i
beat you again that's
perfect scenario yeah echo charles we
started talking about making a
warrior kid bow what do you think i
think that that's a great idea yeah what
age
dud can a kid get like a bow that's
freaking like
pretty legit i i think
probably by seven or eight they can be
going down the right path where you can
teach some solid fundamentals and
get something set up for them yep that's
the warrior kid age too
coincidentally we might have to keep
going down that path
awesome dudley anything else i'm good
right oh man
awesome well like i said earlier man
thanks for thanks for everything you've
done for
the archery community thanks for what
you're doing for all the vets all over
the place
and and really you know thanks for what
you've done for me i know that you like
i said
silver platter man it's been freaking
awesome i appreciate it
um and all you got back from me was a
freaking broke
neck and a freaking brown paper sack for
instructions yesterday
i figured you nearly drowned i broke
your neck and almost drowned you i'm
from the best man
i'm just a savage he calls his friend
josh over to like give me a board so i'm
like oh man this is freaking awesome
like
he didn't even like deliver the cherry
he like had someone else make the cherry
and then freaking just
threw me into the freaking soup
freaking watch me drown seaweed and
get that 40-foot leash that was my board
wrapped around my
neck 15 times yeah
look i'm not the best guy in the world
i'm sorry
but i appreciate your efforts back at me
uh thanks for telling us everything you
learned today like i said it's not just
about archery it's about life it's about
business it's about moving forward
and thanks to your dad and his service
and
and thanks to all the vets out there and
thanks to the
current service members out there around
the world protecting our freedom when
you get done with that mission
you're gonna need a new mission check
out some archery man
it's good for you and to the people out
there in service
here at home to police law enforcement
firefighters paramedics emts dispatchers
correctional officers border patrol
secret service and all the other first
responders
thanks for protecting us in our times of
need
and to everyone else out there
just remember that bow hunting is like
life the winds don't come easy and you
don't always win
you don't always win but you still have
to prepare
you still have to get the reps you still
have to go
through the process and you have to
keep going keep trying to improve
so that you can get what you are
after and until next time
this is john dudley and echo and jocko
out